SIXTY SECONDS SO UP LET ME CALL
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES
TO ORDER. HI GOOD MORNING I
WILL AGAIN BE MAKING SEVERAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO EXPLAIN
THE NEW PROCESS SEES THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE OUR
ESSENTIAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC. I DID THIS- AT OUR
LAST SESSION AND OUR FIRST OUR
RULES SESSION AS WE HAVE COME
BACK INTO OUR TO SESSION- AS IT
RELATES TO THE TECHNICAL SIDE
OF THINGS FOR THE HEARING. AND
IN RESPONSE TO COPE IN NINETEEN
EMERGENCY IN TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC OUR SENATORS AND ARE
SENATE STAFF. WE WILL CONTINUE
TO LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING.
HAS MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS
TO NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC HAS
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. BY CONDUCTING THE
HEARING IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC AND OUR EMPLOYEES. WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARING-
HERE IN THE STATE CAPITOL WITH
ONE OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SENATOR BATES. AGAIN
PARTICIPATING IN THE HEARING
REMOTELY WITH THE USE OF VIDEO
CONFERENCE SYSTEM. I TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENTS THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN TODAY'S
PARTICIPATION NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND YOU WOULD
ENTER THE ACCESS CODE. EIGHT
FIVE SEVEN NINE SEVEN FIVE ZERO
WILL REPEAT THAT AGAIN-
AGAIN IT IS ON THE SCREEN EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX. SIX
FOUR ACCESS CODE. EIGHT FIVE
SEVEN NINE SEVEN FIVE ZERO WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT A
MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE.
AND AT THAT TIME YOU MAY
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. HE'S
KNOW THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON. PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE SO
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY HEAR YOU.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE BE ABLE
TO HEAR YOU AND WE CERTAINLY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND YOUR PATIENCE.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
AND EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE
TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS ADJUSTING TO NEW
ONLINE TOOLS HOW OFTEN HAVE WE
FORGOTTEN TO AMUSE OURSELVES-
SO PLEASE BE PATIENT TO THE SO
EVERYONE CAN BE HEARD. BEFORE I
FORGET ON BEHALF OF OUR
STENOGRAPHER WHO IS- REMOTELY
AT PARTICIPATING IN OUR
BUILDING I ASK ALL SPEAKERS MY
COLLEAGUES AND WITNESSES A LIKE
TO SPEAK SLOWLY AND CLEARLY. SO
BEFORE WE BEGIN TODAY'S AGENDA
WE NEED TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM
SO- AS A REMINDER MEMBERS
YOU'LL NEED TO TURN YOUR
MICROPHONE ON FOR ROLL CALL AND
OF COURSE EVERY TIME WE VOTE SO
MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MINING HERE ON
IN HERE RALPH HERE ROB HERE
WILK PRESIDENT LOOK PRESENCE
ATKINS YEAR I CAN SEE HERE.
ALWAYS THROW ME FOR A LOOP BY
YEAH I DO PRESENT SHE SAID IT
MADE HER UNCOMFORTABLE SO I
SWITCHED TO HEAR HEAR THANK YOU
VICE CHAIRMAN. SENATOR BATES IS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FROM HER
DISTRICT OFFICE TODAY SHE WILL
BE PARTICIPATING IN COMMENTS
QUESTIONS AND DEBATE BUT SHE
WILL NOT BE VOTING. SO WILL
BEGIN OUR AGENDA ACTUALLY
BEFORE WE DO I WANT TO BUY IT I
HAVE TO POINT OUT MY MASK I
BELIEVE IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
WEAR MASKS. AND I WANT TO THANK
THE INDIVIDUAL THAT SENT ME
THIS INCREDIBLE MASCOT TO
CHANNEL DOLLY PARTON ONE OF MY
FAVORITE PEOPLE IN THE WORLD.
SO IF WE ARE GOING TO ENJOY
THIS MOMENT LET'S SO LET'S LET
ITREFLECT SO- I'D TO THAT
INDIVIDUAL THANK YOU FOR THIS
INCREDIBLE MASK. WILL BEGIN-
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OUR
APPOINTMENT MISTER STEVEN P.
GORDON WHO IS THE DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES. MISTER GORDON WELCOME
I THINK WE HAVE YOU WITH US.
AND MA'AM WELCOME WE APPRECIATE
YOUR BEING WITH US TODAY-
REMOTELY LET ME ASK IF THERE IS
ANYONE YOU WANT TO INTRODUCE
ITS WITH YOU WE WELCOME THOSE
INTRODUCTIONS YOUR HER YOU'RE
OFF. SUPPORT STRUCTURE AND THEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD WITH ANY
OPENING COMMENTS YOU'D LIKE TO
MAKE. AND THEN I'LL MOVE TO
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS OF THE
SENATORS DIRECTLY SO WELCOME GO
AHEAD MR GORDON. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SO GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS THAT THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDERING MY
CONFIRMATION AS A DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES. I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE MY WIFE DEBRA
WITHOUT HER I WOULD NOT BE IN
FRONT OF YOU TODAY AND I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO RECOGNIZE MY SON
JACK FOR HIS SUPPORT ON THIS
JOURNEY. THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SERVE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
IS A GREAT HONOR AND ONE THAT I
TAKE SERIOUSLY- THE GOVERNOR
GOT IT RIGHT WHEN HE INTRODUCED
ME. AND SAID WE FOUND A NEW
DIRECTOR OF THE DMV SOMEONE WHO
WANTED TO DO IT. REIMAGINE THE
DMV IS AN OPPORTUNITY OF A
LIFETIME AND A CAPSTONE PROJECT
FOR MY CAREER. MY TEAM AND I
ARE DEDICATED TO MODERNIZING
THE DMV FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING APPLICATION OF
TECHNOLOGY MODERN APPROACHES TO
OUR SERVICES REACHING OUR
CUSTOMERS WHERE THEY ARE.
ENABLING SERVICES FOR MOBILE
DEVICES LAPTOPS KIOSKS BRICK
AND MORTAR LOCATIONS AND EVEN
THE US MAIL. MADAM CHAIR AND
CENTERS I THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION I'M
COMMITTED TO MAKING DMB WORK
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I'D BE HAPPY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER GORDON
I- WILL GO FIRST AND FOREMOST
TO SENATOR BATES. WHO IS NOW
BECOME- AN EXPERT AT
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY WELCOME
SENATOR BATES THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE
CAN- WONDERFUL I I'VE
ACCOMPLISHED THE BIGGEST TASK
KNOWING HOW TO WORK WITH. AFTER
I WAS THERE REALLY COUNTS SO
THAT'S GREAT BUT
CONGRATULATIONS MISTER GORE
NINE YOUR I'LL CLING TO THAT.
ON YOUR RESUME SPEAKS- WONDERS
IN TERMS OF WHAT YOU'LL BE ABLE
TO BRING TO I THINK A MYRIAD OF
PROBLEMS THAT WE'VE HAD AT THE
DMV. EVEN IN PARTICULAR IN THE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY ASPECTS
ARE BETTER ACCEPTED OF MANY
ITEMS AND PROBABLY FIRST ON MY
LIST OF STUFF MOTOR VOTER
SITUATION AND JOB GET A FEW
COMMENTS ON THE BALLOT IF YOU
WOULD ABOUT HOW YOU'RE
APPROACHING OUT SINCE WE HAD. A
NUMBER OF PROBLEMS SPECIFICALLY
ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE REGISTERED
FOR A PARTY THEY DIDN'T USED TO
BE AND THAT WAS ACTUALLY
ACTUALLY THAT WAS BIPARTISAN
WENT BACK AND FORTH AND THEN I
NUMBER YOU WERE- ACTUALLY- I
GUESS REGISTER TO VOTE WHEN
PROBABLY THEY DIDN'T REALLY
MEET THE QUALIFICATIONS TO DO
THAT. SO IF YOU COULD SHARE
WITH ME ON YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THAT I KNOW IT'S PROBABLY STILL
GOING FORWARD- THAT WOULD BE
GREAT NEED TO HEAR THAT AND I
THINK OUR PUBLIC NEEDS TO HEAR
THAT. AND SECONDLY I'LL LET YOU
KNOW WHAT WE'RE HEARING IN OUR
DISTRICT LEVEL AND YOU CAN
IMAGINE YOU'RE PROBABLY HEARING
IT YOURSELF. THE PROBLEM WITH
SADDAM. WE ARE IN DRIVING TO
FOR OUR- OUR PROBABLY ARE
TEENAGE IMPROVE. THAT HAVE BEEN
PUT Q. AND DON'T KNOW WHEN
THEY'LL GET BACK YEAH. AND ARE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT SHOT YOU
WANT OPEN OUT TIME FOR THEM TO
BE ABLE TO DRIVE. IN THIS IS A
REAL PROBLEM FOR FAMILIES ON
MISTER GORDON AS OUR PARENTS GO
BACK TO WORK. AS BUSINESSES ARE
OPENING IN CHILDREN WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE- FOR GETTING
THEMSELVES WHERE THEY NEED TO
GO. ON THAT I THINK YOU'RE ALL
COUNTY NOT GOING OUT JOHNNY CAN
DRIVE YOU KNOW GET MAYBE JOHNNY
WILL BE ABLE TO SO. I'M TRYING
TO BE ABLE TO ACCELERATE THAT.
IN THE NEAR TERM- OF AB
CONTRACTING OUT WITH ARE SAFE
DRIVING SCHOOLS WHATEVER MIGHT
BE ON YOUR MIND ANNUAL THEY
HAVE DONE THAT IN THE STATE OF
COLORADO. SO THOSE TWO ISSUES
ARE HIGH ON MY LIST. AND
LOOKING AT YOUR RESUME I THINK
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT YOU WILL BE VERY
ACCOMPLISHED OUT. OF YOU KNOW
DEALING SO. EITHER GIVING YOU A
HIGH FIVE SO LET'S HEAR. WHAT
YOU MIGHT BE ABLE TO HELP ME
WITH. THANK YOU SAID OUT
PRECIADO. THE CONFIDENCE. I'M
MOTOR VOTER ON AS THAT MANY OF
YOUR- THE- PROGRAM HAS TO START
UP SAID THAT'S KIND OF HOW I
THINK EITHER ERNST AND YOUNG
ASSESSMENT THAT WAS JUST UNDER
WAY WHEN I WHEN I JOINED.
REALLY I HIGHLIGHTED I THINK
TWO THINGS ONE IS THERE IS A
GOVERNMENT ISSUE BETWEEN THE
VARIOUS PARTIES PRIMARILY THE
DMV AND THE SECRETARY OF STATE.
AND I MET WITH THE SECRETARY OF
STATE AND WE HAD I THINK A
REALLY GOOD CONVERSATION ABOUT
HOW WE WOULD HAVE THE RIGHT
GOVERNMENT'S MAKING SURE
THERE'S CLEAR COMMUNICATION
ABOUT WHAT THE SCOPE IS. TESTED
WHO TEST WHAT WHAT SUCCESS
LOOKS LIKE. AND I THINK WE
FOUND DOES TO. CLARIFYING THE
SCOPE HAVING VERY FREQUENT
MEETINGS CERTAINLY AND THE AND
IN THE EARLY WEEKS. WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO REALLY TIGHTEN UP OUR
ABILITY TO EXECUTE ON. SO I
THINK RIGHT IS WHAT I'VE SEEN
IS THAT. FROM THAT THE
GOVERNMENT BETWEEN THE TWO
ARMOS THINGS ARE WORKING AS AS
WELL AS THEY'VE EVER DONE AND
WE'RE SEEING THAT. THINGS MAKE
AN INTRODUCTION RELEASE IS
BEING MADE. WITH NO DEFECTS IN
AND THAT'S CERTAINLY A VERY
DIFFERENT. FEELING THAN WHAT IT
WAS SIX MONTHS AGO I THINK THE
TEAM IS WORKING WERE THERE
AWHILE TOGETHER. A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY. AND BUT I THINK
RIGHT NOW THINGS ARE GOING WELL
ON THE OPERATION SIDE AND I'LL
GET BACK TO YOUR QUESTION
SENATOR- ABOUT. SOME OF THESE.
ISSUES BUT THE ARMY OPERATIONS
I WHICH IS THE OTHER FAT FAST
ENOUGH TO SAY WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE- HOPE THAT. AS
SERIOUSLY AS IT NEEDED TO BE
AND WE ALSO. RECEIVED FUNDING
FROM THE GENERAL FUND WHICH IS
WHERE IT SHOULD BE FUNDED. WE
HAVE DEDICATED TEAM TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT PROCESS WORKS.
AS EFFICIENTLY AS AGAIN THERE
ARE. FEDERAL GUIDELINES. OF
DAYS. PROCESS THE TEAM HAS PUT
RIGHT MEASURES IN PLACE TO MAKE
SURE THOSE THINGS MAKE IT
THROUGH THE SYSTEM TO THE
SECRETARY STATE AND EVENTUALLY
TO THE REGISTER VOTERS WITHIN
THE TIME FRAMES- DICTATED BY
LAW IT'S NOT PROCESS HAS BEEN
VERY WELL MEASURED OF LATE- IN
AGAIN VERY WELL EXECUTED OF
LATE I THINK THE TEAM IS FIXED.
TWO OF THE MAJOR PROBLEMS CAN
GOVERNOR'S BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENTS AND MAKING SURE
OPERATIONALLY THAT WHERE WE
HAVE OUR AYE IF YOU WILL ON THE
BALL NOW I KNOW THERE'S BEEN
SOME CONCERNS RAISED BY SOME
SOME PARTS WHERE- SOMETHING HAD
CHANGED SO AND I KNOW THAT THE
PROCESS IS- IS A BIT CONFUSING
ABOUT. WHEN YOU'RE A SE.
REQUESTING A DUPLICATE DRIVER'S
LICENSE OR DOING A CHANGE OF
ADDRESS WHERE WE TAKE YOU
THROUGH THE- THE MOTOR VOTER
PROCESS AGAIN. AND TO THE BEST
COMPLEX AND WE'RE WORKING TO
SIMPLIFY IT. THE ITEMS THAT
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT FORWARD OUT
FROM- VARIOUS GOT CONSTITUENTS
IN THE FIELD I THINK HAVE BEEN.
LOOKING THAT OUR DEPARTMENT I
THINK ALSO THROUGH THE
SECRETARY STATE. I'M NOT SURE
WE FOUND. MANY IF ANY AND I
APOLOGIZE. IF THERE ARE SOME
THAT YOU'RE AWARE BUT- WHERE
YOU KNOW WE ARE SOME SOMEHOW
INADVERTENTLY THINGS WERE
CHANGED. BUT BECAUSE OF THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE PROCESS IS
WHAT I'M LOOKING AT IT. THAT
IT'S VERY EASY TO. NOT KEEP
YOUR MOTOR VOTER PREFERENCES
STATIC WHEN YOU DON'T WANT TO
CHANGES I KNOW THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S COMING OUT IN A FUTURE
RELEASE SO THAT. WE WON'T.
NOBODY WILL HAVE. BE BE
CONFUSED ABOUT WHAT WHAT BUT
DISLIKE ON AND SO ON SO I THINK
AGAIN. A HIGH LEVEL OF THE
MOTOR VOTER IS IN A VERY VERY
GOOD STATE WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO WATCH FOR THOSE ITEMS THAT
YOU MENTIONED. WE. TAKE THIS
VERY SERIOUSLY AS I WAS
CONCERNED. COME IN AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF ISSUES SO THAT. IF THERE IS
A DEFECT OF SOME SORT THAT WE
ADDRESS THAT. NOW YOU TALK
ABOUT TRIED TO **** DRIVE JUST
IS LIKE THE NUMBER ONE EMAIL
THAT I GET. AND I DO RESPONDED
MANY BECAUSE REGION I'M NOT
ASKING FOR MORE FROM YOUR
CONSTITUENTS BUT- IT'S REALLY
GOOD TO BE. IN TOUCH WITH OUR
WITH OUR COMMUNITY. AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT IN FACT WE DO
RESPOND APPROPRIATELY I'M DR
DOES HELP. S WE OPEN UP OUR
NEXT WE'VE LOST AS WE'VE BEEN
OPENING IN THREE WAYS THE NEXT
WAVE OPEN SOMETIME MIDDLE OF
THIS MONTH. AND THAT WILL START
TO INCLUDE DRIVE COUSIN. WHY WE
PUT THAT IN THE LAST PHASES
SOCIAL DISTANCING WHILE ON A
CAR IS CHALLENGING RIGHT. IT'S
A WE'RE TRYING TO GET THE RIGHT
PP IN PLACE THE RECORD FEATURES
IN PLACE. AS A LOT OF PRE AND
POST WE'RE GONNA TEST. BUT WE
BELIEVE WILL HAVE THAT STOOD
UP. THIS MONTH. AND THEN WE'VE-
ALSO STREAMLINED THE PROCESS SO
WE HAVE THINGS THAT ARE DRIVE
BECAUSE PEOPLE WOULD NORMALLY
DO. YES SOUP TO NUTS IN THE
PROCESS WE NOW. SEPARATE IS
SOME OF THAT WORK SO THEY CAN
STAY FOCUSED ON THE DRIVE HAS
TO BE EFFICIENT. GET A FEW MORE
DRIVES IN EVERY DAY. AND SO
THAT'S GOING TO HELP I THINK.
WORK OFF THE EXISTING
DEPLOYMENTS IN THE BACKLOG AND
ALLOW FOR MORE POINTS HAPPEN IN
THE NEAR FUTURE. AND WE ARE.
SENATOR TEACH YOUR COMMENTS WE
ARE IN DISCUSSIONS WITH.
PRIVATE INDUSTRY TO SEE IF WE
CAN ACTUALLY IS. I TRIED TO
SCHOOLS PEOPLE THAT ARE GONNA
HAVE. VERY VERY. STRONG
BACKGROUNDS NO NO DIDN'T IF YOU
WILL TO MARRIAGE AGAINST NOPE
NO. REPORT OF PROBLEMS. OR ALSO
LOOKING AT THAT YEAH TELL. AND
THERE'S A LOT OF REALLY GREAT
TECHNOLOGY THAT CAN TELL YOU.
HOW YOU'RE DRIVING HOW WHILE
YOU'RE DRIVING- XCELERATED
DECELERATING AND SO ON. AND
FROM THAT COULD BE A PROXY FOR
SAFETY. IT'S MASS NOT READY FOR
PRIMETIME THE DMB WE ARE
ACTIVELY LOOKING AT THAT SO.
MAYBE EVEN A CONCERT WITH DRY
SCHOOL SO. WE'RE NOT READY TO
DO ANYTHING WITH THE DRY SCHOOL
TODAY WE ARE IN ACTIVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE WOULD USE US
AS AN ACCELERATOR. TRULY. TO
KNOCK ON THE BACK ON SENATOR.
WELL WILL THANK VERY MUCH. OF
THIS GOING ALL. SOUND VERY ON.
HOPEFUL IN OF THE ISSUES OUT SO
CERTAINLY PLAYED OUTSIDE THE
DISTRICT LEVEL SO A LOT MY
DOUBTS TOO YOU'LL AND I'M GONNA
WIN AYE CANDLES AND I'M BACK IN
PERSON THERE ARE YOU WILL HAVE
MY SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTER. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- CENTER MONEY LET ME START
WITH YOU. THANK YOU ANA. MADAM
CHAIR IN. MISTER GORE AND I
ALSO WANT TO OFFER MY
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT AND THANK YOU FOR
STEPPING UP TO BRING OVERSIGHT
AND REFORM TO THE DMV AND NOW
DEALING WITH THIS AMIDST THE
COVERT NINETEEN I KNOW THAT YOU
HAVE OVER NINE THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES. WORKING UNDER YOUR
SUPERVISION AT THE DMV COULD
YOU SHARE WITH THE COMMITTEE-
AND THE PUBLIC THE STEPS YOU'RE
TAKING TO PROTECT EMPLOYEES TO
PROTECT. ESTA MURDERS AND I
KNOW THERE'S BEEN SOME RE
OPENING OF OFFICES WHAT IS THE
SCHEDULE- FOR THE RE OPENINGS-
CONSISTENT WITH THE PROTECTIONS
NECESSARY FOR CODE NINETEEN
THANK YOU. GREAT THANK SENATOR
SO FOUR OUT THE PROTECTIONS AND
WE'RE TAKING THE STANDARD PP
PROTECTIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR EMPLOYEES OUT FACEMASK
WE'VE ALSO IN SOME PLACES ARE
NOT ALL PLACE THANK YOU WE
GIVEN THEM SHE LOOKED OLDER
OPTIONAL FOR THEM TO WEAR
CORSET WORK GLOVES. AND THERE'S
CLEANING MATERIALS AT THOSE IT
AS YOU KNOW WITH MANY
INDUSTRIES WERE IN SHORT SUPPLY
SO ACTED TAKE US AWHILE TO GET
THOSE IN PLACE BUT NOW THEY'VE
BEEN SUPPLIED TO OUR SITES AS
THE OPEN WE MAKE SURE OF COURSE
OUR SUPPLY CHAIN IS SOLID SO WE
WON'T RUN OUT. SO THAT'S THE
FIRST THING WE'RE GOING TO MAKE
SURE EMPLOYEES STAY STATE WE'VE
ALSO TAKEN CHAIRS OUT OF THE
LOBBY WE COULD HAND WASHING
STATIONS IN MANY OF OUR DMV'S
OUR CUSTOMERS CAN'T. GATHER
CLOSER THAN THEY SHOULD AND
THEY ALSO HAVE A CHANCE OF YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE MAJOR
PROTECTIONS FOR WASHING YOUR
HANDS. AND LASTLY WE ASK OUR
OUR CUSTOMERS ACTUALLY REQUIRE
CUSTOMERS TO WEAR SOME SORT OF
FACIAL COVERAGE REDUCING THE
REST OFFER THEM FOR
TRANSMITTING TO OTHER PEOPLE IN
THE LOBBY BUT ALSO TO OUR
EMPLOYEES AND LIKE WAYS WITH
OUR OUR EMPLOYEES WEARING A
MASK. IT REDUCES THE RISK OVER
ALSO I THINK GENERALLY SPEAKING
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH GENERAL SORT OF PP
WE ALSO OF COURSE ARE DOING
SOME CONTRACTS WHICH IS
RECOMMENDED BY CALLIE CHAR AND-
AND SO WE ASK OUR EMPLOYEES
BEGINNING EVERY DAY ABOUT IT DO
THEY HAVE A FEVER. YOU HAVE
BEEN AROUND ANYBODY WITH THE
ROUTE THEY TRAVEL TO COUNTRIES
WHERE. YEAH THIS STOP THE
SYMPTOMS ARE COMING NINETEEN
NINETY MORE PREVALENT IT'S TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY
YEAH REDUCING RISK BY MAKING
SURE THAT PEOPLE SUFFERING
COURT WHERE THEY CAN'T. THAT
HAS BEEN I THINK FAIRLY
SUCCESSFUL OF COURSE WE'VE BEEN
IMPACTED BY CO IN NINETEEN-
WITHOUT AYE FORTY ONE CASES TO
DATE AND BUT ALL OF THOSE
PEOPLE HAVE SUCCESSFULLY RETURN
TO WORK- SITES HAVE BEEN
CLEANED WE HAVE AN ACCENT WE
FOLLOW LOCAL HEALTH AUTHORITIES
SO. IF IT HAPPENS IN ORANGE
COUNTY EVER HAPPENS IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY WE MAKE SURE
WE LINK UP WITHOUT THOSE HEALTH
AUTHORITIES WE FOLLOW THEIR
PROTOCOLS TO. SOME OF THE
THINGS WE'VE DONE I THINK TO
PROTECT A THE STAFF ON ON NOW.
I'M CO IN EIGHTEEN UNDER THE
QUESTION WITH THE FACT THAT WE
DON'T NEED WE ARE WE'RE IN THE.
SECOND PHASE WE CAN HAVE A
OPENING A SERIES OF ALL. EVERY
COP OF WEEKS. SO OUR FIRST
TRYING BOXES WILL TWENTY. SIX
RETAIL. AND OF OUR BUSINESS
DEALER IN FINANCE. TO AND SO ON.
WE OPENED ANOTHER. SO ABOUT A
AGO THEN. CIVIL UNREST HAPPENED
SO WE ACTUALLY HAD A- RAMP
THOSE DOWN A LITTLE BIT BUT WE
JUST. ARE STARTING I REOPEN IT
AGAIN TODAY AT FULL STRENGTH OF
THOSE FIRST TWO. WAVES SAVE
FOR- ONES THAT ARE IN-
UNSETTLED AREAS OF TO SAY THAT.
OUR NEXT WAY WILL OPEN WE
BELIEVE IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
WEEKS. AND WHEN WE DO THAT THAT
WILL ALSO COME WITH. A SLOW
RAMP UP OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO ON A DRIVE TO SO WE EXPECT
TO BE BY THE END OF JUNE. TO BE
FULLY BACK IN BUSINESS. RUNNING
AND HOW WHAT IS NOW THE NEW
NORMAL. THANK YOU AND IF I
COULD JUST GO BACK TO THE CODE
NINETEEN. YOU MENTIONED FORTY
ONE CASES. WHAT IS THE PROTOCOL
IF A- AN EMPLOYEE. REPORTS TO
BE SYMPTOMATIC OR TESTS
POSITIVE IN A COVERT NINETEEN.
TEST WHAT. WHAT STEPS ARE
TAKEN- TO PROTECT EMPLOYEES WHO
MAY HAVE HAD CONTACT WITH
EMPLOYEE- AND OR WITH. PUBLIC
HEALTH AUTHORITIES. YEAH AND SO
ON IN THAT CASE IN ACTUALLY IN
EVERY CASE WE CONTACT THE LOCAL
HEALTH AUTHORITIES SHOES AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL. IN THE END HE'S
COUNTY FORTY HAS A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT PROTOCOL WE FOLLOW
THAT PROTOCOL SO THEY MENTIONED
CASES IN OUR COUNTY WE FOLLOW
THE ORANGE COUNTY HEALTH
OFFICIALS CASES IN RIVERSIDE
AND FOLLOW THEIR- THEIR
PROTOCOL AND THAT INVOLVES
EVERYTHING FROM. NOTIFYING
PEOPLE WITH COURSE WERE WERE
ALSO WORRIED ABOUT YOU KNOW
THAT IF YOU WILL THE HIPAA
REQUIREMENTS WITH RESPECT TO
THE SAME SOMETHING SPECIFIC
ABOUTAN INDIVIDUAL WE DO
NOTIFY EMPLOYEES WE FOLLOW THE
PROTOCOL WHETHER THAT IS TO YOU
YOUR CLEAN IN REAL MINOR CLEAN
WAIT AND REOPENED WHAT WHATEVER
THE PROTOCOL IS BY. BY AREA WE
FOLLOW THOSE TO THE LETTER.
CASE IT INVOLVES. TOM I CALLS
BALLS CLEANING THE FIVE THERE'S
A PROTOCOL FOR CLEAN THIS SITE
PROTOCOL IT'S BEEN ESTABLISHED
AND THEN IF THEY IF THE HEALTH
AUTHORITIES BELIEVE IT'S
PRUDENT WE BRING BRING PEOPLE
BACK THE NEXT DAY OR THE DAY
AFTER THAT WHATEVER THE
WHATEVER IT TAKES TO GET IT
DONE IN CASE YOU HAVE ANY CASES
RIGHT WE HAVE SOMEBODY WHO
HASN'T BEEN A WORK IN A AND A
COUPLE OF WEEKS BUT EVERY SELF
REPORTED- THE OTHER THEY'VE
THEY'VE HAD THE SYMPTOMS ARE SO
OF THE FAMILIES SOMETIMES. AND
AGAIN WE FOLLOW LOCAL
AUTHORITIES BUT I WILLBUY MY
RECALL REQUIRE A DIFFERENT
APPROACH BUT AGAIN IT COULD
FALL IN THE LOCAL HEALTH
AUTHORITIES WHATEVER THE
REGULATIONS ARE THAT'S WHAT WE
WANT THANK YOU FOR YOUR ANSWER
ON THAT IN THE INTERESTED IN
TIME I'LL JUST CLOSE WITH THE
QUESTION- WE DID HAVE AN-EXTENSIVE CONVERSATION
YESTERDAY ABOUT THE- REAL ID
AND IN THOSE DEADLINES BEING
PUSHED BACK THAT GIVES THEM
BEING CALIFORNIANS A LITTLE
MORE TIME- BUT- FOR MY FINAL
QUESTION. OF MISTER. GORDON I'D
LIKE TO ASK YOU ABOUT. NOT ONLY
YOUR- BUT WHAT YOU ARE DOING TO
IMPLEMENT- A CHANGE OF CULTURE
IN TERMS OF CUSTOMER SERVICE.
YOU WE HEAR OF STORIES OF-
THERE IS REPORT A FEW YEARS AGO
OF AN EMPLOYEE WHO IS. SLEEPING
ON THE JOB WE'VE HEARD OTHERS
OF- KIND OF A JOKE ABOUT DMV
EMPLOYEES NOT BEING. THAT PLATE
TO CUSTOMERS OR- HOW DO YOU
CHANGE THAT CULTURE WITH NINE
OVER NINE THOUSAND EMPLOYEES TO
CREATE. TO MAKE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS CUSTOMERS. NUMBER ONE
IN THE MISSION OF THE DAM.
EXCELLENT QUESTION THANK YOU
SENATOR YOUR CULTURE IS THE
MOST CHALLENGING THING THAT WE
TRY TO OVERCOME EVERY SINGLE
DAY THE GOOD NEWS IS I HAD A
CHANCE TO VISIT A FIFTY ONE
DIFFERENT FIELD OFFICES AND I
FOUND A VERY ENERGIZED
WORKFORCE. AND I'M REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THAT BECAUSE WHAT
YOU READ ABOUT IN THE PRESS WAS
THAT THERE WERE PROBLEMS VERY
MUCH SENATOR LIKE YOU JUST
MENTIONED. BUT I FOUND PEOPLE
THAT- ARE INSPIRED BY OUR
VISION THEY ARE INSPIRED TO
HELP OUR CUSTOMERS THEY ARE
OPEN TO NEW WAYS OF DOING
THINGS. AND WHEN I GOT THEM AND
I SHARE THE IDEAS OF WHAT WE'RE
DOING AND HOW WE'RE DOING IT I
THINK THEY'RE VERY EXCITED NEED
TO BE ABLE TO RAPIDLY IMPLEMENT
THANKS TO CALL THE NINETEEN
MANY OF THESE THINGS IS VIRTUAL
FIELD OFFICE THAT WE
ESSENTIALLY START UP OVERNIGHT.
YOU KNOW THEY HAVE THE ABILITY
TO IMPLEMENT AND OPERATE THAT
REALLY AND I AND I I'M A
RADICAL CHANGE IN JUST A COUPLE
OF DAYS I REALLY DISPELS IN MY
MIND THE MISSILES WELL THE
STATE EMPLOYEE NOT WILLING TO
DO THINGS AND- THE GAS BECAUSE
YOU SAID. I'M NOT SEEN ANY
EVIDENCE OF THAT ABOUT THE WHAT
I HAVE SEEN IS A VERY AND
INSPIRE TEAM BUT IT SEEMS THAT
NEEDS TO BE LIKE NOW YOUR
QUESTION CULTURE. CULTURE IS
THE MOST CHALLENGING THING WE
HAVE SO THAT'S GOING TO START
WITH ME IT'S GOING TO START
WITH MY LEADERSHIP TEAM AND WE
NEED TO MODEL THE RIGHT.
CULTURE REALLY IS DO WHAT ARE
THOSE NORMS AND WHAT IT WHEN
THEY ALWAYS SAY THE CULTURE IS
REALLY WHAT YOU DO WHEN NOBODY
ELSE IS LOOKING. WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ON THE
RIGHT. NOBODY ELSE IS LOOKING
AND THAT MEANS WE- RESPECT WHEN
YOU RESPOND WITHIN SERIOUSLY
AND AS I MENTIONED IT WHEN WE
SPOKE- JUST YESTERDAY I GAVE
SEVERAL CUSTOMERS I'M SINGLE DO
I LOOK ANOTHER SCREEN AND A
COUPLE TO CUSTOMERS AND ENGAGE
WITH YOM THEY'RE- RAISING
ISSUES BUT IT'S GREAT FOR ME TO
HAVE VISIBILITY BUT IT'S ALSO
GREAT FOR ME TO. WORK WITH MY
STAFF AND WORK WITH PEOPLE ON
ON LINE TO SAY THAT IT'S OKAY
TO REACH OUT TO CUSTOMERS
LOCATED TO DO THINGS IN NEW
WAYS AND TAKE FEEDBACK AND HOLD
OURSELVES ACCOUNTABLE. AND
LASTLY I THINK WE NEED MEASURES
AND I THINK WE SPOKE ABOUT THIS
YESTERDAY WE'RE DOING SOME
BUSINESS PROCESS RE ENGINEERING
THESE BIASED REMAPPING WITH ALL
THESE THINGS TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND HOW IS. THE PROCESS
WORKING. AND IT'S NOT BECAUSE
WE WANT TO REDO. CYCLE TIMES.
ALL THE DO. BUT THAT HASN'T IN.
THAT IS THE COST FOR. YOU KNOW
HOW ANY LONGER TO PROCESS WE
MAKE. RIDGE TO UNNECESSARILY.
BECAUSE WE YOU ARE TO. IS OVER
THE- AND IT REALLY CHEAP SIMPLE.
EVERYTHING WE DO THE SIMPLE.
EVERY WE DO THAT TO MEASURE AND
CREW OUR- STAGE NOT ONLY. THE
STATE TIME AND TERMS OF THE
RESOURCE. CAST COMPLETED TASK
BUT ALSO TASTE CUSTOMER. SO
THEY CAN PUT THAT. VALUE TO
WORK I CAN TAKE OF. A CHILD
TAKE CARE OF A GRANT. YOU CAN
GO TO WORK THEY DON'T HAVE TO
SPEND SO MUCH TIME IN THE DMV
SO. IT'S ALL OF THOSE THINGS
OVER TIME THAT IF WE CONTINUE
TO MODEL THE RIGHT BEHAVIOR
MEASURE THE RIGHT THINGS.
REINFORCER I THINK THAT WE
WILL. SEE THE SEA CHANGE OF
CULTURE AND I HOPE YOU'LL SEE
IT. IN HOW CUSTOMERS PERCEIVE
US TODAY ARAB THESE PRETTY THIS
TOMORROW. AND I'M DOING
EVERYTHING IN MY POWER TO MAKE
THOSE CHANGES SENATOR. WELL
THANK YOU DIRECTOR GORDON
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR-
ENTHUSIASM I LIKE THAT YOU'RE
VIEWING THIS IS THE CAPSTONE OF
YOUR PROFESSIONAL CAREER. IN
THE YOU BRING THAT. SKILL SET
AND ENTHUSIASM TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO THANK YOU AND
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. I THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR MONNING LET ME TURN TO
OUR VICE CHAIRMAN SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM- PRO
TEN- CONGRATULATIONS- MR
GARDEN- LIKE. ON YOUR POINT AND
I AM I PLAN TO VOTE FOR YOUR
CONFIRMATION TODAY. ACTUALLY
THE QUESTIONING FOR CENTER
BASIS OR MINING WAS QUITE
EXTENSIVE AND FRANKLY- COVERED
ALL THE AREAS- THAT I AM
INTERESTED IN. ARE YOU DID SAY
ONE THING THOUGH IT'S KIND OF
A- INTRIGUING TO ME AND IT'S
KIND OF A SIDE BAR BUT- MANY MY
PARENTS WANT THEIR KIDS BACK IN
SCHOOL IN THE FALL AND COURSERS
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT. AND I'VE
I'VE TOURED MANY SCHOOLS AND I
THINK THERE'S ENACT INADEQUATE
INFRASTRUCTURE AS RELATES TO
BATHROOMS IN BEING ABLE TO
WATCH HER HANDS AND WHAT HAVE
YOU AND YOU MENTIONED ABOUT
HAND WASHING STATION SO I JUST
CURIOUS IF YOU CAN WALK US
THROUGH THAT BECAUSE THIS MAY
BE SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
TAKE- TO OUR SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION. SURE SURE
WE HAVE A VERY CREATIVE TEAM.
BACK TO SENATOR MONIES COMMENT-
DISPELLING THE MYTHS WE HAVE A
VERY CREATIVE TEAM IN OUR IN
OUR FIELD- THEY HAVE- THEY SAID
OKAY WE'RE GONNA NEED HANNAH.
WE NEED PEOPLE TO WASH YOUR
HANDS EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE. YOUR
BATHROOM FACILITIES THAT ARE.
ARE THE ENVY IS USUALLY NOT AND
IS NOT INTENDED FOR COMPLETE
HAND WASHING EVERYBODY'S COMING
THROUGH. SO CREATED AS A ARE
THEY WENT OFF THEY RENTED FROM
THESE RENTAL COMPANIES THESE
PORTABLE HAND WATCHES AGENCY A
CONSTRUCTION SITE. I THINK THEY
SAW SOMEBODY AT A SUPERMARKET
HEY THERE'S A REALLY GOOD IDEA-SO. I THINK YOU KNOW THEY WERE
THEY FELT IN ENABLE THEY FOUND
EMPOWER TO GO OFF AND DO THAT
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO SO
THEY'VE NOW PUT THOSE OUT AT.
OUR DMV'S AND YOU'LL SEE THEM
AGAIN LOBBYIST HIM OUT IN THE-
IN THE PARKING LOTS JUST SO
CUSTOMERS CAN. YOU KNOW YEP
FURTHER INSULATE THEMSELVES OF
THE CROP SO GETTING VERY
CREATIVE EIGHT EIGHT THEY
CALLED A COUPLE OF COMPANIES.
AND HEY THEN THEY TOOK ACTION
BECAUSE THEY KNEW EVEN IF IT
WAS A TEN PERCENT. REDUCTION IN
THE RISK. YEAH THEY TOOK THE
ACTION AND I KEPT THEIR
EMPLOYEES ARE EMPLOYEES. SAY
FOR ANY KEPT THE PUBLIC PAPERS
WELL. GREAT JUST I JUST WANT
AGAIN WOULD JUST ONE FINAL
COMMENT. I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT
YOUR COMMITMENT. TO NEW
TECHNOLOGIES. I HATE TO BE A
HOMER BUT IN MY HOME TOWN
CENTER CREATED WHICH IS NOW THE
THIRD LARGEST CITY IN LA
COUNTY. ARE DMV'S BEEN AT THE
SAME LOCATION LIKE. HI FORTY
FIVE YEARS ANYWAY AS LONG AS
I'VE LIVED THERE. HORRIBLE
INGRESS AND EGRESS. AND WAY TOO
SMALL FOR A COMMUNITY OF THAT
SIZE SO. ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO
ALLOW PEOPLE TO ACCESS.
SERVICES IN ALL PLATFORMS I
THINK I THINK IT'S A GOOD THING
BECAUSE WITH HIS BUDGET. CRISIS
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE NOT GONNA GET
NEW DMV FACILITY ANYTIME SOON
ALTHOUGH WE'VE MY COMMUNITY
CERTAINLY DESERVES THAT. SO
WITH THAT I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO SUPPORTING YOUR CONFIRMATION
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER. THANK YOU MUCH LAST
CERTAIN NOT. SENATOR ROTH WILL
TURN IT OVER YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM TEM MR. CAN GUIDE.
LISTENING TO THE QUESTIONS AND
YOUR RESPONSES I HAVE TO SAY
THAT. ARE YOUR RESPONSES- ARE
THE MOST DETAILED AND
COMPREHENSIVE RESPONSES THAT I
THINK I HAVE HEARD FROM ANY
WITNESS DURING MY- TIME ON THIS
RULES CMMITTEE AND IT'S
CERTAINLY VALIDATE YOUR SECURE
YOUR SELECTION IN YOUR
APPOINTMENT TO NOMINATION BY
THE GOVERNOR SO LIVE I ACTUALLY
HAVE NO QUESTIONS. I THINK WERE
VERY VERY FORTUNATE TO HAVE YOU
WITH THE HOME OF A- OF A
DEPARTMENT THAT IS CERTAINLY
HAD ITS CHALLENGES I'M
CONFIDENT THAT YOU WILL. TACKLE
THOSE AND MAKE OUR DEPARTMENT
OF MOTOR VEHICLES OF THE
BENCHMARK FOR THOSE IN THE
OTHER STATES IN THE UNITED
STATES SO. REGULATIONS I LOOK
FORWARD TO MOVING YOUR-
CONFIRMATION AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANKS THANK YOU SENATOR
ROTH- I BUT I ALSO DON'T HAVE
QUESTIONS I THINK YOU'VE
COVERED A LOT OF GROUND AND IN
THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE ALREADY
ASKING IN YOUR COMMENTS. I WILL
OUR ECHO SENATOR MINING IN
I'D ALREADY WRITTEN DOWN WAS.
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH YOUR
ENTHUSIASM AND YOUR APPROACH
THIS IS SUCH A CRITICAL
SERVICE- TO CALIFORNIANS IN
CONSTITUENTS AND- YET- ARE THE
ONLY THING THAT HAS REPLACED
CALLS ABOUT THE DMV HAS BECOME
CALLS ABOUT EDT ARE
UNDERSTANDABLY RIGHT NOW. SO
IT'S SOMETHING- MY STAFF-
FREQUENTLY- IT FROM MY DISTRICT
OFFICE IS CALLING ABOUT AND I
JUST WANT TO. SAY WE HOW MUCH
WE APPRECIATE YOUR STAFF
RESPONDING SO QUICKLY TO US I
WANNA MAKE SURE YOU HEAR THAT
BECAUSE WE COUNT ON IT. AND
THEY DO AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE
YOU KNOW WE APPRECIATE IT. I
THANK SENATOR ABSOLUTELY THE
LAST THING I WILL SAY TO. GO
ALONG WITH MY VICE CHAIRMAN. IS
THAT YOU WILL HEAR FROM US FROM
SAN DIEGO WE HAVE A DMV THAT
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO DO A
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP AND-
WORK WITH THE COMMUNITY FOR
ALMOST A DECADE I INHERITED IT
FROM MY- PREDECESSOR SENATOR
KEY HELLO. AND WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THAT- IT'S A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN
FIGURE THAT OUT BUT- JUST PUT
IT ON YOUR RADAR SCREEN I DON'T
NEED ANYTHING RIGHT NOW- BUT
YOUR- YOUR YOUR STAFF HAVE BEEN
VERY WELL TO WORK WITH US ON
THAT ISSUE AS WELL. I AM. I
HAVEN'T SAID A JUST A FEW
COMMENTS I THINK WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND MOVE I TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO WANT TO TESTIFY
AND WE WILL START WITH-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WE'LL
BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE-
INTO THE WITNESSES TO ENSURE OF
COURSE OUR SOCIAL DISTANCING
DON'T FORMAL LINE ONLY ONE
PERSON AT A TIME AT THE
MICROPHONE ONCE THAT WITNESS
CONCLUDES THE NEXT WITNESS MAY
COME FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE.
SO ANYONE IN THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE. OKAY SEEING NONE I THINK
THAT OBVIOUSLY MEANS WE
PROBABLY DO NOT HAVE ANYONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE WHICH IS OUR
OVERFLOW. ROOM I JUST DOUBLE
CHECKING NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. OKAY OUT WITH THAT- WE
WILL MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELEPHONE CONFERENCE SERVICE.
AND I KNOW THAT WE HAVE A
MODERATOR THAT I WILL INTRODUCE
RIGHT NOW MISS- MISTER OR MS
MODERATOR WHOEVER HAPPENS TO BE
THERE IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROP
THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF DIRECTOR
STEVEN GORDON. WE WILL BEGIN.
ABSOLUTELY IN LATE AND JOHN ON
THE PHONE LINES THE PRE IN
SUPPORT OF DIRECTOR GORDON-
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. DON'T INDICATE IN PLACING
QUEUE OPERATE WILL PROVIDE YOU
A NUMBER AND YOU WILL BE
ANNOUNCED BY THAT NUMBER WHEN
YOU'RE READY YOUR COMMENTS
AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND AS OF NOW IT LOOKS
LIKE WE DO FOR THAT ARE IN OUR
QUEUE. THANK YOU SO MUCH OUR GO
AHEAD. AS OF THE FIRST WILL GO
TO NUMBER EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS JIM LIGHTS
PARTNER WITH CALIFORNIA
STRATEGIES CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF MISTER STEVE GORDON-
APPOINTMENT AND CONFIRMATION AS
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES. I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH MISTER
GORDON IN SEVERAL DIFFERENT
CONTEXTS INCLUDING THE DIGITAL
LICENSE PLATE PILOT PROGRAM THE
DEPARTMENT HAS UNDER WAY AND
THEN CERTAINLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIRPORTS COUNCIL AND
THE IMPLEMENTATION THE REAL ID.
MR GORDON WAS KIND ENOUGH TO
COME TO OUR AIRPORT BOARD
MEETING LAST FALL MADE A VERY
ENGAGING PRESENTATION TO THE
AIRPORT TO ACTORS. AND WE'VE
ALL THERE'S ALWAYS FOUND HIM
ACCEPTABLE AND- RESPONSIVE AND
WE CERTAINLY SUPPORT HIS
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT WILL BE GOING TO NUMBER
TWENTY NUMBER TWENTY YOUR OWN.
HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS SCOTT WEDGE ON BEHALF
OF THE DISTANCE LEARNING
COMPANY. THE INTERACTIVE
EDUCATION CONCEPTS INCORPORATED
THE UNIVERSAL AECOM CALL CENTER
AND TRAFFIC SAFETY CONSULTANT.
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF
DIRECTOR GORDON THAT DMV HAS
RECENTLY TAKEN ON A MUCH NEEDED
REFORMS OF THE ON LINE I
DRIVERS- TRAINING SCHOOLS AND
WE APPRECIATE- THE PROGRESS
THAT THEY'VE MADE AND WE WOULD
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
NUMBER SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS ERIC SOUR NINE THE
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASSOCIATION
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION
AND FIFTEEN HUNDRED MEMBERS WE
SUPPORT CONFIRMATION OF MISTER
GORDON. AS A DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES.
IT'S THE OPPORTUNITY EVEN HIS
TEAM TO PUT FORTH INTO
STREAMLINING MANY PROCESSES ARE
MEMBERS UTILIZED. AND MOST
RECENTLY IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT PANDEMIC WE CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH MEMBERS OF THIS TEAM
ON ALMOST ON A DAILY BASIS TO
ENSURE THE TRUCKING INDUSTRY IS
ABLE TO CONTINUE. TO PROVIDE
THE ESSENTIAL GOODS AND
SERVICES THAT CALIFORNIANS NEED
DURING THIS TIME PRESIDENTE
TIME. PGA IS ALWAYS ENJOYED A
GREAT WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE DMV FOR THE PAST MANY YEARS
AND LOOKS FORWARD TO THAT
CONTINUED RELATIONSHIP WITH
DIRECTOR GORDAN. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS. NEXT TO
GO TO NUMBER FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD NUMBER FIFTEEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE THAT THE
THAT THOMPSON ON THE SENIOR
VICE PRESIDENT FOR AYE DAMIA
AND I LEAD THE BED NETS THAT
ARE PARTNERS WITH DIRECTOR
GORDON CALIFORNIA DMV TO
PRODUCE YOU ARE. A DRIVER'S
LICENSE WITH WE PROBABLY DO A
LOT OF THOUGHT SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA ABOUT MORE BROADLY-
WE PRODUCE THE DRIVER'S LICENSE
BURKE THIRTY FIVE OTHER STATES.
AS WELL AND I CAN CERTAINLY
SAY- THAT YOU HAVE A VERY
SPECIAL UNIQUE- LEADER IN
DIRECTOR GORDON. A VERY FRESH
PERSPECTIVE- TO SERVING
CALIFORNIA TRANSFORMING DMB IN
PROVIDING. A REALLY INCREDIBLE
VISION FOR THE REST THE DMB
INDUSTRY TO WERE VERY PROUD. TO
PARTICIPATE TODAY IN A CARING
AND VERY SUPPORTIVE OF A
RECOMMENDATION BOB BERG
DIRECTOR GORDON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER MODERATOR WE CHECK THE
LINE AGAIN TO BE SURE WE'VE
HEARD FROM ALL OF THE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. ABSOLUTELY ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU ARE AN ORDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. A WE DID HAVE ONE MORE
QUEUE UP IT'LL JUST TAKE A
MOMENT WONDERFUL THANK YOU. AND
THE NEXT WE WILL BE GOING TO
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR. WELCOME BUT
GO AHEAD NUMBER TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M LARRY
LASKOWSKI EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE INDEPENDENT AUTOMOBILE
DEALERS ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
OUR GROUP FULLY SUPPORTS THE
FINAL WORD ON FOR DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES. A SHORT TIME MISTER
GORDON HAS PROVEN TO BE A
COMPETENT LEADER THE DMV.
DESPITE CHALLENGES FROM THE
CALL THE CRISIS WHILE HE WAS
STILL LEARNING IS ROLE. IN A
SCHEME A DMV SUCCEEDED IN
PUBLISHING RULES FOR ONLINE
AUTO SALES AND HOME DELIVERIES.
TO OUR GROUP AND BEEN WORKING
ON WITH THE NB FOR MANY YEARS.
AS A SPECIAL GUEST AT OUR
ANNUAL CONVENTION THIS PAST
OCTOBER MISTER GORDON WELCOMED
INTERACTION WITH OUR AUTO
DEALER MEMBERS. IDEX SUPPORTS
IS APPOINTMENT AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO FUTURE COLLABORATION
WITH THEM AS YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. AT THIS
TIME I'M SEEING NO FURTHER IN
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY HAVING HEARD IT FROM
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WELL NOT
NOW FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR. FROM ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
WILL BEGINHERE IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE I LET ME ASK
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE APPOINTMENT. OKAY SEEING
NINE ARE ALSO ASSUMING THERE IS
NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE BUT
WILL CHECK ANYONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE WE WILL COME BACK TO YOU
MISTER MODERATOR AND- MOVE ON
TO THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY- VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE. PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO THE
APPOINTMENT. LATER JOHN ON THE
PHONE LINES IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE
ZERO IF YOUR IN OPPOSITION. AT
THE TIME WE HAVE ZERO IN Q. BUT
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NOBODY IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER MODERATOR-
WITH THEY ACT. LET ME- MAKE
SURE AND COME BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES- ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FOR MY
COLLEAGUES. SEEING NONE SENATOR
OFF I THINK THAT'S YOUR CUE
MOVE THE GOVERNMENT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THERE IS A MOTION-
MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MONNING AYE
MINING I ROTH HI ROB I WILK HI
WELCOME I ATKINS AYE ATKINS AYE
WHAT IS YOUR FORTY ZERO- YOU
HAVE BEEN CONFIRMED DIRECTOR
GORDON CONGRATULATIONS. YOUR
MATCH THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY. WE WILL TAKE A
MOMENT AND SHIFT GEARS LET ME
JUST LOOK TO SEE IF WE NEED TO
TAKE- LET ME ASK THE
STENOGRAPHER MISSILE BLOCK ARE
YOU GOOD TO GO. WONDERFUL I
WILL GO AHEAD AND INTRODUCE
MISTER ALFA V. JOHNSON THE
DIRECTOR OF THE STATE LOTTERY
WELCOME DIRECTOR JOHNSON I
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US
TODAY. LET ME ASK IF YOU HAVE
ANYONE YOU WOULD LIKE TO
ESPECIALLY RECOGNIZE AND THANK-
AND THEN. GO RIGHT INTO YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS AND THEN WE
WILL MOVE RIGHT TO SENATORS FOR
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS THAT
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE I NOTICED YOU WERE
HERE FOR THE WHOLE. FIRST PART
OF THE CONFIRMATION OF MISTER
GORDON SO WE'RE HAPPY TO
WELCOME YOU HERE NOW. THANK YOU
MADAM PRO TEM I'M HAPPY TO BE
HERE AND- I KNOW MY FRIENDS AND
FAMILY ARE WATCHING REMOTELY.
WELL THEY'RE PRACTICING SAFE
SOCIAL DISTANCING. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM PRO TEM MR VICE
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
COME BEFORE YOU TODAY I AM
HONORED AND I AM GRATEFUL TO
THE GOVERNOR FOR POINTING ME AS
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LOTTERY. I ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE MY FAMILY. MEMBERS
WHO ARE WATCHING THIS DURING
THE MOBLIE. ESPECIALLY MY WIFE
JENNIFER AND MY SON PARKER.
WITHOUT HIS LOVE AND SUPPORT MY
CHEAPENS BUT NOT IMPOSSIBLE.
PUBLIC EDUCATION HAS PLAYED AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN MY ENTIRE
LIFE AND CAREER. WHILE AN
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
THIRTY YEARS AGO. I WORK IN A
LOTTERY FUNDED MENTORSHIP
PROGRAM AT NEWARK MEMORIAL HIGH
SCHOOL IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
IN THAT JOB I EXPLAIN DIFFERENT
PATHWAYS TO HIGHER EDUCATION TO
UNDER REPRESENTED STUDENTS. AND
THAT WORK HAS INSPIRED MY
CAREER EVER SENSE. MY
GOVERNMENT AND PUBLIC POLICY
EXPERIENCE SPANS OVER TWENTY
FIVE YEARS. AND INCLUDES WORK
ON EDUCATION POLICY AND
GOVERNMENT GAMING ISSUES FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
WITH NATIVE AMERICANS SOVEREIGN
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS. MY CAREER
HAS INCLUDED WORK IN
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSIS POLICY
DEVELOPMENT AND PRACTICE. ON
SUBJECTS INCLUDING K. TWELVE
EDUCATION POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. INDIAN AFFAIRS AND
GOVERNMENT GAMING. THE UNIQUE
CAREER OPPORTUNITIES I GAME
THROUGH MY EDUCATION POLICY
BACKGROUND AND GOVERNOR
GOVERNMENT GAINING EXPERIENCE
PROVIDING ME WITH A STRONG
SENSE OF THE LOTTERY'S MISSION
AS WELL AS INSIGHT INTO THE
DYNAMICS OF THE GAMING INDUSTRY.
THE CALIFORNIA LOTTERY HAS A
UNIQUE ROLE IN STATE
GOVERNMENT. ALL PROFITS FROM
THE SALE LOTTERY TICKETS
SUPPORT THE FULL RANGE OF
PUBLIC EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA.
FROM ELEMENTARY TO UNIVERSITY.
IN ADDITION ON SPENT AND
MINISTRY OF FUNDS AND UNCLAIMED
PRIZES EACH YEAR ARE ALSO SENT
TO PUBLIC EDUCATION. LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES SUCH A
SCHOOL DISTRICT THE SITE WHERE
AND HOW THE LOTTERY MONIES
SPENT. IN OUR MOST RECENT FULLY
AUDITED FISCAL YEAR
200-017-2000 EIGHTEEN THE
LOTTERY GENERATED MORE THAN ONE
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS FOR
PUBLIC EDUCATION MORE THAN EVER
BEFORE. THESE FUNDS TOTALING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR MANY
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR KEY STUDENT
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES. SINCE
ITS INCEPTION OVER THIRTY YEARS
AGO THE LOTTERY HAS PRINCIPALLY
FOCUSED ON ESTABLISHING ITSELF
AND FULFILLING ITS MISSION BY
RAPIDLY GROWING SALES. THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
TREMENDOUSLY SUCCESSFUL IN THIS
REGARD AS ITS CONTRIBUTIONS TO
EDUCATION OVER THE LAST NINE
YEARS HAVE INCREASED FROM ONE
BILLION TO ONE POINTEIGHT. A
RECORD HIGH. THIS IS THE RESULT
OF DEDICATED WORK FOR MORE OVER
EIGHT HUNDRED STATE EMPLOYEES.
MANY OF WHOM HAVE WORKED FOR
THE LOTTERY FOR A DECADE OR
MORE. TODAY THE CALIFORNIA
LOTTERY IS A KEY INFLECTION
POINT IN ITS HISTORY. I'LL JUST
HAVE BEEN POSED BY NEW
TECHNOLOGY. CHANGING CONSUMER
PREFERENCES AND CRISES SUCH AS
THE COVERT NINETEEN AND THEN.
TO MEET OUR MANDATE TO MAXIMIZE
THE FUNDING WE GENERATE FOR
PUBLIC EDUCATION OUR OPERATIONS
MUST WORK BETTER AND SMARTER.
WE MUST DIRECT MORE ATTENTION
AND RESOURCES TO ESTABLISHING A
MORE MATURE AND STABLE
ORGANIZATION. WITH BETTER
PROCEDURES CONTROLS
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
TO ACCOMPLISH THESE GOALS WE
ARE SYSTEMATICALLY WORKING TO
IMPROVE LOTTERY OPERATIONS
STARTING FIRST WITH MANAGING.
BY FAILING KEY ROLES OPENING
LINES OF COMMUNICATION AND
ENCOURAGING MORE T. MORE. WELL
WE HAVE MADE PROGRESS IN THE
LAST YEAR THERE IS MUCH WORK
STILL TO BE DONE. AND WE WILL
FIX PROBLEMS WHEN WE FIND.
FINALLY I WANT TO ASSURE YOU
THAT I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS
RAISED IN RECENT AUDITS. PLEASE
KNOW THAT WE ARE ADDRESSING
THESE FINDINGS
ADMINISTRATIVELY. AND I'VE
ALREADY BEGUN TO IMPLEMENT
IMPORTANT CHANGES THAT WILL
HELP ADDRESS THE INTERNAL
CONTROL GAPS THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED. OUR MANAGEMENT TEAM
WILL REVIEW AND STRENGTHEN ALL
DEPARTMENT POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES FROM TOP TO BOTTOM
TO ENSURE THEIR FALL IN
PRACTICE. THIS WILL IMPROVE
EFFICIENCIES AND HELP US BETTER
CALL OUR MISSION. IN DOING SO
HE WILL REBUILD THE PUBLIC'S
TRUST AND RESTORE CONFIDENCE IN
OUR DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU AAIN
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO COME
BEFORE YOU TODAY. I APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND I
WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH DIRECTOR JOHNSON
LET ME ARE START WITH ACTUALLY
SENATOR BTES REMOTELY AND THEN
I'LL GO TO SENATOR ROTH. THANK
YOU- SENATOR ATKINS AND ALL
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENTS ON MISTER JOHNSON-
I KNOW WE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
THE FOR THE- KOBE IS SHUT DOWN.
I TO MEET IN MY OFFICE AND AT
THAT TIME I THINK YOU WERE VERY
IMPRESSIVE AND SHARING THAT YOU
WERE THERE TO REFORM AND YOU
HAD PLANNED TO DO THAT ARE A
CERTAIN NEED THE YOUNG MONEY
THE THIRTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS
OWED TO THE SCHOOL. WHAT'S HOT
HIGH ON THE LIST OF THINGS THAT
NEEDED TO BE LOOKED AT AND I
INVESTIGATED IN MORE DETAIL. SO
I AM STILL THERE WITHOUT ISSUE
ARE VERY VERY IMPORTANT I KNOW
THAT MY COLLEAGUES ON BOTH WHO
WILL BE SPEAKING TO YOU ON THE
VERY FOLLOWING YOU WILL
PROBABLY TALK ABOUT THAT ALSO
BUT I THINK UP IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR YOU AND YOUR STAFF TO KNOW
THAT THAT. AT THE MOMENT WITH
THE HUGE DEFICIT WE HAVE IN OUR
BUDGET THING WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN TO OUR SCHOOLS OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM THAT CERTAINLY
IS MY NUMBER ONE PRIORITY TO
SEE THAT YOU ARE ADDRESSING
MATTER NOW AFTER YEARS SOME
SOLUTION- IF THE PAIN BACK ON
TAKES LONGER DANCE. IS A
SHORTER TERM WE WOULD HOPE FOR
THAT CERTAINLY UNDERSTANDABLE
BUT I THINK WE ALL NEED TO KNOW
TIMELINE ON NOW. AND OUT TO ALL
OF THE FORCES THAT ARE THERE
ARE WORKING VERY DILIGENTLY ON
THAT ISSUE- I THINK YOU'VE COME
TO THE AGENCY WITH A GREAT
BACKGROUND I THINK WE DISCUSSED
THAT. AND JOHN WHEN YOU'RE THE
REFORM AGENT A LOT IS ON YOUR
SHOULDERS WE HAVE YOUR STAND
THAT THAT I THINK YOU'RE UP TO
THE CHALLENGE BACK I GO AGAIN
BOTTOM LINE COMMON DENOMINATOR
IS GOING TO BE THAT ONE DAY SHE
GOT UP. CERTAINLY FORMAL
STARTING A LOT OF YOU KNOW OUR
CONSTITUENTS OUR PARENTS AND
OUR CHILDREN OUT THERE SO WE
OWE THANK YOU FOR YOUR COULD
NOT MATCH. AND WISH YOU WELL
AND NINE BE OOKING FORWARD TO
SEEING YOU WHEN I CAN ACTUALLY
BOTH CHARLIE IN PERSON. ON THE
FLOOR THE LEGISLATURE. THANK
YOU VERY FOR YOUR- I RE PRE. I
ENJOY CHANCE WE MILLION PER IF
YOU AGO. SINCE SINCE SINCE. OR
THIRTY YEARS AGO. CALIFORNIA
LOTTERY HAS ALWAYS FOLLOW THE
LOTTERY ACTS OVER ARCHING
MISSION. MAXIMIZE FUNDING FOR
EDUCATION. OVER THE LAST NINE
FISCAL YEAR'S LOTTERY HAS GROWN
ITS CONTRIBUTION TO PUBLIC
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA. FROM
ONE BILLION TO ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION. IT IS IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THE LOTTERY ACT
MANDATES THAT ALL PROFITS.
ADMINISTRATIVE SAVINGS AND
UNCLAIMED PRIZES BE TRANSFERRED
TO EDUCATION EVERY YEAR. THERE
ARE NO WHAT LEFTOVER FUNDS IN
ANY YEAR. IN FISCAL YEAR
200-017-2000 EIGHTEEN WHICH IS
THE YEAR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR'S REPORT FOCUSED ON.
THE LOTTERY PROVIDED ONE POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS TO
EDUCATION. REQUIRING A LOTTERY
TO ONLY FOLLOW MANDATE OF
STRICT PROPORTIONALITY BETWEEN
SALES REVENUES AND EDUCATION
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT YEAR. WOULD
HAVE RESULTED IN APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
LESS IN FUNDING FOR EDUCATION.
THIS IS BECAUSE IN ORDER TO
FOLLOW THE STRICT
PROPORTIONALITY MANDATE THE
LOTTERY WOULD HAVE HAD TO STOP
SELLING CERTAIN POPULAR AIDS
AND OVERALL SALES REVENUES
WOULD THEN HAVE FALLEN BY MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. THANK THANK YOU FOR
THAT EXPLANATION AND THOROUGHLY
GOING FORWARD WILL- WE'LL GET
THINGS WORKED OUT FOR A
CERTAINLY THE LOTTERY AND AGAIN
OUR EDUCATION ISSUES. THANK-YOU. VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES LET ME TURN TO US
SENATOR ROTH. APPROACH HIM IS
TO DIRECTOR CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU SIR LET ME SAY AT THE
OUTSET THAT I FULLY INTEND TO
SUPPORT YOUR CONFIRMATION BUT I
DO HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
IN MY- OTHER JOB OF PURELY SO
LAST YEAR SO I OR TWO I'VE
BEEN. FOCUSED ON EDUCATION
FUNDING AND SO I PAYED
ATTENTION WHEN THIS- STATE
AUDITOR'S REPORT CAME OUT IN
FEBRUARY OR MARCH OF THIS YEAR.
AND OBVIOUSLY IT BECAUSE SOME
COMMOTION AMONG THE- AND
EDUCATION COMMUNITY WITH
RESPECT TO FUNDING AND- I'M NOT
GOING TO GET INTO THE THIRTY
SIX MILLION OR WHATEVER IT IS
TODAY BECAUSE THE- IT SEEMS TO
BE SOME CONFLICT IN BETTER THAN
THE REPORT OVER. NET REVENUE
AND HAS THAT HAVE THAT CAL IS
CALCULATED IN THE DEFINITION
SET FORTH IN THE GOVERNMENT
CODE SECTION. IN THIS OF THAT
POSTERS WAS THIS RATHER-
INTERESTING CONVERSATION ABOUT
PROPORTIONALITY IN WHEN I READ
IT I NOTED YOU KNOW PORTION OF
TO WHAT YOU KNOW
PROPORTIONALITY REALLY DOESN'T
HAVE. MEETING UNLESS YOU TALK
TO ME ABOUT AS A ONE FOR ONE OR
ONE FOR TWO OR ONE FOR THREE
AND- THEN WE UNDERSTAND WHAT
PROPORTION IT REALLY MEANS BILL
WE DON'T KNOW THAT. REALLY
BASED ON. I GUESS THE LANGUAGE
OF THE LOTTERY ACT BUT I DO
WANT TO FOCUS ON THE TWO
THOUSAND TEN AMENDMENTS AND-
PERFORMANCE SINCE THEN AND WHEN
I READ THE REPORT I NOTED THAT
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND TEN
ACCORDING TO REPORT. AND THOSE
AMENDMENTS THE LOTTERY. TOTAL
REVENUE INCREASED BY A HUNT ONE
HUNDRED AND 15% AND THE FUNDING
PROVIDED TO EDUCATION INCREASED
BY. 66% NOW I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
MEASURE THAT I WOULD THINK THAT
IF THE TOTAL REVENUE INCREASED
BY ONE HUNDRED AND 15% AS A
PERCENTAGE THAT THE FUNDING
PROVIDED TO EDUCATION WOULD
ROUGHLY INCREASED BY ABOUT ONE
HUNDRED AND 15% BUT SOME
ADJUSTMENT. NECESSARY IF THE
PRIZE POT INCREASED SO MY FIRST
QUESTION IS TRULY A TWO PARTER.
IS THAT A GOOD THING ONE
HUNDRED AND 15% AND 66% AND HOW
TO Y. SS THAT PERFORMANCE IN
TERMS OF THE SPREAD. BETWEEN
TOTAL REVENUE AND EDUCATION
FUNDING. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION. YOU KNOW I SPENT A
LOT OF TIME WITH THEIR STAFF
TALKING ABOUT THESE DIFFERENT
CALCULATIONS AND- YOU'RE RIGHT
IT'S- COMPLICATED. AND WE GOT
TO SPEND A LOT OF TIME- DIGGING
INTO THE NUMBERS AND EXPLAINED
IN DIFFERENT WAYS AND WE SPENT
SIX MONTHS LAST YEAR TRYING TO
EXPLAIN THE DETAILS TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT REALLY CUT
THROUGH ME WHEN WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THIS IS HOW I KEY.
VARIABLE THE CALCULATION HAS
NOT BEEN BROUGHT OUT IN THE
PUBLIC DISCUSSION. IN PRESS
ACCOUNTS OR IN VARIOUS REPORTS.
ACOSTA PRICE IS EIGHT. WATERY
SALES ARE DONE IN A VOLUNTARY
FASHION. IF WE WERE TO MAKE
PEOPLE BUY LOTTERY TICKETS WE
CALL IT TAX SO THE WAY THAT THE
LOTTERY MOTIVATES SALES IS BY
OFFERING MORE AND BETTER PRICES
TEN YEARS AGO THE BILL YOU
REFERENCED AB ONE FORTY TO.
ALLOW MORE PRICE FLEXIBILITY
ALLOWING LOTTERY THE LOTTERY
COMMISSION TO DETERMINE WAYS TO
REALLY CHANGE THE POT THE PRIZE
PAYOUT STRUCTURE SO THAT IT
WOULD BE MORE ATTRACTIVE TO
PLAYERS TO PLAY CERTAIN GAMES
NOW WHY IS THAT WITH JACKPOT
GAMES YOU HAVE A TYPICAL PAY
OUT OF ABOUT 50% I'M TALKING
ABOUT LIKE FOR EXAMPLE THE-
THE- THE VERY SHOCKED JACKPOT
GAMES LIKE MEGA MILLIONS OR
POWERBALL OR SUPERLOTTO PLUS.
ALL OUR SCRATCHERS GAMES WHERE
THE LOTTERY DERIVE 70% OF ITS
REVENUE WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
HIGHER PRICE PALE. KNOWN PLAIN
ENGLISH WHAT THAT MEANS IS WE
MAKE LESS MONEY ON. BUT THEY'RE
VERY POPULAR AND THAT'S WHY
SCRATCHERS GAMES THE INSTANT
TICKET GAMES ACTUALLY GENERATE.
THE MAJORITY OF THE LOTTERY
SALES. WITH THE PRICE
FLEXIBILITY GRANTED TEN YEARS
AGO IN AB ONE FORTY TWO WHAT
THE LOTTERY WAS ABLE TO DO IS
INTRODUCE EVEN HIGHER PRICE
POINT GAMES. GAMES AT THE
SCRATCHERS- IN THIS WRITER'S
CATEGORY THAT RENT TWENTY
DOLLARS. AND SO I'M GOING TO
ASK WILL WHY WOULD SOMEONE BY
THAT BUT THE THING IS A LOT OF
OUR CORE PLAYERS LOVE THOSE
GAMES BECAUSE THEY COME IN
VARIOUS STYLES AND BERRIES PLAY
WHAT. FOR AND SO WE FOUND THAT
WHEN WE INTRODUCED THOSE GAMES
WE WERE ABLE TO GENERATE EVEN
MORE SALES WITH THOSE
CATEGORIES AND BECAUSE THE
PRICE PALE RANGES FROM 50% TO
AS HIGH AS 60% SOME CASES EVEN
MORE YOU END UP HAVING A
BLENDED RATE. WHERE ULTIMATELY
UP TO SPEND MORE MONEY IN
PRICES TO GENERATE HIGHER
SALES. NOW AS I EXPLAINED
EARLIER AND AS EVERYBODY KNOWS
THE NET PROFITS WE TAKE THOSE
SALES MINUS THE COST OF THE
PRICES. MINUS ACOSTA
ADMINISTRATIVE EXPENSES
UNCLAIMED PRIZES AND- OTHER-
ARE FEES TO OPERATE THE GAMING
SYSTEM THAT'S WHAT YOU HAVE
LEFT NONPROFIT GHOST EDUCATION.
SO I GUESS SHORTER ANSWERS LIKE
THIS. THE LOTTERY OF THE LAST
DECADE SEND THE SPEND MORE
MONEY AND PRIZES GENERATE
HIGHER SALES. OUR THIS. SALES
WERE FLAT BY ABOUT THREE OR
FOUR YEARS THERE WAS NO BROKE.
AND THE LOTTERIES MISSION AS
SET FORTH IN THE LOTTERY ACT
ABOUT THIRTY FIVE YEARS AGO WAS
TO MAXIMIZE SUPPLEMENTAL
FUNDING FOR EDUCATION TO DO
EVERYTHING IT COULD. TO RAISE
MORE MONEY FOR PUBLIC EDUCATION
SO WITH FLAT SALES THERE HAD TO
BE A CHANGE IN THE WAY THE
LOTTERY DID THINGS TO GENERATE
MORE SALES. AND AS I EXPLAINED
THE LOTTERY IF THIS AFTER THE
LEGISLATURE GRAND THAT CHANGE
LAW BY OFFERING MORE AND BETTER
PRICES IN CERTAIN CATEGORIES
WHICH ARE MORE ATTRACTIVE SOME
PLAYERS AND THUS. GENERATING
HIGHER SALES AND AS I EXPLAINED
OF THE LAST NINE YEARS WE'VE
INCREASED THE CONTRIBUTION
RESULTING FROM THE SALES TO
EDUCATION. FROM ONE MILLION TO
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS. SO I THINK ULTIMATELY
THE METRIC SHOULD BE. HOW IS
THE CONTRIBUTION EDUCATION
GROWN OVER TIME. IT WAS FLAG
BEFORE THE CHANGED YEARS AGO
NOW IT'S INCREASING ON A
REGULAR RATE. I DO TO RECENT
EVENTS REPUBLICAN HAS IT BEEN
WHICH USUALLY A BIT OF A CHANGE
IN THAT HOWEVER OUR THREE YEAR
STRATEGIC PLAN WHICH STILL HAS
TO BE APPROVED BY THE
COMMISSION. HAS A GOAL OF
REACHING THE LEVEL OF
CONTRIBUTION TO PUBLIC.
EDUCATION OF TWO BILLION
DOLLARS. SO WE'RE ALWAYS ON A-
TO GENERATE MONEY FOR SCHOOLS
AND LOOKING FOR MORE AND BETTER
WAYS TO DO THAT. SO JUST GET TO
GET BACK TO MY FIRST QUESTION
YOU ANSWERED IT UP. THE ****
ACCOUNTS FOR THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN ONE HUNDRED AND 5015%
AND SIXTY SIX PERCENT. IS THE
INCREASE IN THE PIES IN THE
PRIZE POT. THE AMOUNT OF PRIZE
MONEY THAT WAS DISTRIBUTED-
THROUGH THE LOTTERY CORRECT.
THAT'S RIGHT WE SAT HIGHER
PAYOUTS ON SOME GAMES AND THAT
IS BASICALLY DRIVEN SALES. NOW
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE'S A REQUIREMENT IN THE
LOTTERY ACT THAT NOT LESS THAN
EIGHTY SEVEN PERCENT. OF THE
TOTAL ANNUAL REVENUE FROM
LOTTERY SALES GO BACK TO THE
PUBLIC IN THE FORM OF PRIZES IN
FUNDING. FOR EDUCATION IN MY IN
MY CORRECT ON THAT. THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION CENTER THANK YOU
IN FACT. YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE SEEN THAT
I'VE SEEN SINCE I ARRIVED AT
THE LOTTERY IS A LOTTERY IS NOT
GOING TO GOOD JOB. OF TELLING A
STORY BECAUSE ON UNTOLD STORY
OF THAT- STATISTIC THAT YOU
JUST MENTIONED IS THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT GOES OUT IN
COMMISSIONS AND BONUSES. YOUR
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND RETAILERS
ACROSS THE STATE. MANY OF WHICH
ARE SMALL BUSINESSES YOU KNOW
THERE ARE CHANGE AS WELL BUT
YOU KNOW THIS IS IMPORTANT.
THESE ARE IMPORTANT ALWAYS TO
GO OUT TO THE COMMUNITIES AND
SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE MEDICAL
SCHOOL FOR MEDICAL EDUCATION.
AND THE MONEY THAT GOES OUT TO
RETAILERS IN THE FORM OF- OUR
PRICES IN COMMISSIONS. THAT'S
HOW YOU GET TO THE 87% SO GIVE
THAT THEN. ISN'T THE ISSUE HAVE.
TO BALANCE THE AMOUNT OF. PRIZE
MONEY AND I GUESS COMMISSION
AND THE OTHER RELATED
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH PRIZES. THE AMOUNT OF
PRIZE MONEY AGAINST THE NEED TO
FIND EDUCATION SO. IF THAT'S
THE ISSUE THEN HOW DO YOU SET
THE OPTIMUM LEVEL. AND WHAT
OPTIMUM LEVEL SHOULD WE EXPECT
HERE THAT IS THE OPTIMAL LEVEL
OF PRIZE MONEY OFFERED. TO
GENERATE THE NECESSARY TOTAL
REVENUES THAT WE WANT TO
ACHIEVE IN THIS LOTTERY SYSTEM
IN ORDER TO MAXIMIZE THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE
TO FUND. EDUCATION ACROSS THE
STATE. WELL YOU KNOW THAT'S
EXACTLY THE POINT RAISED BY THE
STATE AUDITOR- THEY ASK YOU
KNOW HEY LOOK YOU GUYS HAVE A
PROCESS FOR DETERMINING THE
OPTIMAL PRICE PAYOUT BUT THE
INFORMATION USING IS ALL. SO
SHOULDN'T YOU HAVE MORE UP TO
DATE INFORMATION THAT
DETERMINES THE OPTIMUM PRICE
POINT AND WE AGREE. HE SAID YOU
KNOW WHAT WE NEED TO HAVE A AS
UP TO DATE- RESEARCH AND
INFORMATION THAT WE CAN GET OUR
HANDS ON THAT REALLY SHOWS THAT
THE NUMBERS THAT WE HAVE CHOSEN
IN TERMS OF PRICES AND OTHER
RELATED FACTORS ARE THE OPTIMAL
POINT IT'S A TRICKY NUMBER. NO
WHEN WE HAD TO LEARN
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR BUSINESS
PLAN RESEARCH DIVISION OVER
THIS IT REMINDED ME A LOT OF MY
EXPERIENCE IN GRAD SCHOOL
TRYING TO LEARN CALCULUS SO.
YOU KNOW IT WAS TRICKY STUFF
BUT YOU GOTTA FIND THE OPTIMUM
POINT ON THE CURVE FOR YOU
YOU'LL THE MOST OUR SALES REP.
AND THAT'S THE KIND ON CONSUMER
BEHAVIOR ON THE ECONOMY. ON A
LOT OF DIFFERENT. SHORT ANSWER
IS WE KNOW THIS IS A KEY ISSUE.
THE AUDITOR RAISED. IT WE
AGREE. AND WE'RE IN THE PROCESS
RIGHT NOW TRYING TO FOR OUT.
HOW TO GET NEWER AND MORE UP TO
DATE STUDY THAT HELPS US
DETERMINE THE BEST. OPTIMUM
PRICE PALE. WELL THANK YOU AND
I THINK THE OTHER CHALLENGE YOU
HAVE FRANKLY HAVING TO. BY THE
WAY THROUGH THE STATE AUDITOR'S
REPORT IN THE OTHER MATERIALS
ASSOCIATED WITH A LOTTERY
OPERATION IS. FIGURING OUT A
WAY TO EXPLAIN THIS RATHER
COMPLICATED PROCESS AND THIS
RATHER RATHER COMPLICATED
SYSTEM THAT YOU HAVE TO WORK
WITH. IN ENGLISH SO THAT THOSE
OF US WHO WERE NOT TO MATH
PEOPLE- CAN UNDERSTAND THAT SO
I LOOK FORWARD TO THAT. AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE STUDY THAT
YOU ARE GOING TO THE COMMISSION
ON THE- TRYING TO ESTABLISH THE
OPTIMUM LEVEL. OF PRIZE MONEY
VERSUS TOTAL REVENUE IN FUNDING
FOR EDUCATION AND- I ALSO LOOK
FORWARD TO MOVING YOUR
CONFIRMATION AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME CONGRATULATIONS SIR. THANK
YOU SIR. THANK YOU SENATOR OF
MISTRUST CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU
MADAM PRO TEM- CONGRATULATIONS
ON YOUR APPOINTMENT. COUPLE
THINGS SO LATE LAST YEAR IT WAS
UNVEILED AT THE LOTTERY
GIVEAWAY SCRATCHERS AT THE
ELLEN SHOW AS A PROMOTIONAL
OPPORTUNITY AND SOME STAFF WERE
RECIPIENTS OF FREE SCRATCHERS
AS WELL SO I GOT A COUPLE
QUESTIONS RELATED TO THAT WHAT
IS THE LOTTERIES METHODOLOGY
FOR MEASURING RETURN ON
INVESTMENT FOR ADVERTISING
CAMPAIGNS AND TO HOW DO YOU AS
A AGENCY GOES WAY PUBLIC
PERCEPTION INTO THESE TYPE OF
DECISIONS. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION I REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
STATE LAWS AND LOTTERY
REGULATIONS EXPRESSLY ALLOW THE
LOTTERY TO EXPAND FUNDS FOR
PROMOTIONAL PURPOSES. THIS
EFFORT IS MADE TO MAINTAIN
AWARENESS OF OUR PRODUCTS AND
MOTIVATE FUTURE SALES FUTURE
PURCHASES. THE ONLY SHOW
OFFERED A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO
INCREASE CONSUMER AWARENESS OF
THE LOTTERY'S CONTRIBUTIONS TO
PUBLIC EDUCATION WHILE HELPING
TO DRIVE SALES OR SCRATCHES
DURING THE HOLIDAYS. THE
PROMOTIONAL RUN WITH THE ELLEN
SHOW WAS CONTRACTUALLY WAS A
CONTRACTUAL AGREEMENT THE
CALIFORNIA LOTTERY PROVIDED
EMOTIONAL SCRATCHERS TICKETS TO
THE PROGRAM IN EXCHANGE FOR THE
VALUE OF ADVERTISING LOTTERIES
BRANDON MISSION. BRINGING IN
CHAU INTEGRATION ON THE ELLEN
SHOW WAS TWELVE DAYS OF
GIVEAWAYS DURING THE HOLIDAY
SEASON THE CONTRACT ACTUAL
AGREEMENT. ALL THE STRUCTURES
TO GETS PROVIDED TO THE PROGRAM
FOR AN AUDIENCE YOU HAVE TO
GIVE AWAY. THERE WERE NO
TICKETS MISPLACED OR MISSING
FROM THIS PROMOTIONAL BACK.
THIS IN CHAU SEGMENT THAT WE
WORKED ON WITH THE ELLEN SHOW
FEATURED TELEVISION
PERSONALITIES ON THE GENEROUS
AND JIMMY KIMMEL. ENDORSING THE
CALIFORNIA LOTTERY AND HOW WELL
THEY SCRATCHERS THIS IS MORE
IMPACTFUL THAN TRADITIONAL
TELEVISION COMMERCIAL. I
PERSONALLY WORK WITH OUR
MARKETING TEAM TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE SHORT VIDEO WE
PROVIDED FOR THIS EVENT MEET
SPECIFIC MENTION OF EDUCATION
AND WHAT THE LOTTERY DOES FOR
EDUCATION BECAUSE WE WANT THE
PUBLIC TO KNOW. WHAT WE DO
REPUBLICAN EDUCATION. RENDON
AGGRESSION ON A WIDELY POPULAR
SHOW LIKE ALLEN ALSO HELPS
REACH NEW PLAYERS THAT MAY NOT
OTHERWISE CONSIDER LOTTERY IN
GENERAL OR- A LOTTERY TICKET
JUST A HOLIDAY GIFT. MOREOVER
ELLEN THE GENEROUS IS ALSO A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND PUBLIC EDUCATION.
AND SO WE THOUGHT THIS ALIGNED
PERFECTLY WITH A LOT OF READING
AND OUR MISSION. RIGHT THEY AT
THANK YOU FOR THAT- SO I'VE
BEEN ON THIS COMMITTEE FOR
ABOUT TWO YEARS AND IT'S PRETTY
RARE THAT WE GET LETTERS IN
FROM INDIVIDUALS. AND IN THIS
CASE WE'VE RESTORE I THINK
WE'VE ALL RECEIVED THREE
LETTERS FROM INDIVIDUALS AND IN
OPPOSITION TO YOUR APPOINTMENT-
FIGHTING THAT THERE'S- POOR
CULTURE IN THE AGENCY AND THAT
YOU'RE PROBABLY NOT THE PERSON
TO. TAKE TO THE AGENCY IN A NEW
DIRECTION SO WONDERING A- DO
YOU THINK THERE'S A CULTURAL
PROBLEM THERE AND IF SO WHAT
ARE YOUR STEPS. TO IMPROVE IT.
WELL YOU KNOW AS I MENTIONED IN
MY OPENING COMMENTS AND THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION THE
LOTTERY IS BEEN ALMOST A KIND
OF A START UP DEPARTMENT I
MEAN. THIRTY FIVE YEARS SEEMS
LIKE A LONG TIME BUT AS- WE ALL
KNOW. EACH OTHER STATE AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENTS IT'S PRETTY
YOUNG. AND ITS INITIAL CULTURE
WAS KIND OF A BOOTSTRAP YOU
KNOW RAPID GROWTH. IT WAS VERY
SUCCESSFUL. BUT A LOT OF THE
KINDS OF NORMS AND- PROCESSES
AND CULTURAL ASPECTS THAT YOU
WOULD EXPECT TO SEE IN A MATURE
STATE AGENCY. OUR WERE
UNDERDEVELOPED. SO THAT'S ONE
OF THE THINGS I IMMEDIATELY
SAW. AND IF ONE OF THE THINGS
WE STARTED IMMEDIATELY WORKING.
THESE REFORMS TAKE TIME. BUT
YOU KNOW IT IT'S INTERESTING
SENATOR BECAUSE WHEN I FIRST
ARRIVED YEAR AGO AND WAS
BRIEFED ON YOU KNOW VARIOUS
MATTERS. I FOUND MYSELF ASKING
QUESTIONS LIKE CABLE WHY DO WE
DO THAT I'M THINKING WELL I'M I
DON'T KNOW BECAUSE I'M NEW HERE
RIGHT. AND WHEN PEOPLE ARE
RUMORED SAY WHAT WE DON'T KNOW
EITHER WE JUST ALWAYS DID IT
LIKE THAT I SAID ARE YOU
KIDDING. WE NEED TO DOCUMENT WE
NEED. TO HAVE CONSISTENT
POLICIES AND PRACTICES AND
PROCEDURES. I'VE EXPLAINED MY
STAFF THE LOTTERY STAFF THAT IS
NOT A MATTER OF. IF FOR ALL OF
IT IT'S A MATTER OF WHEN. WE
MUST BE ABLE TO BE TRANSPARENT
AND DEMONSTRATE ACCOUNTABILITY
EVERYTHING WE DO WHETHER IT'S
AN AUDITOR OR REPORTER. OR A
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC FOR A
GENTLEMAN LIKE YOURSELF WAS
ASKING QUESTIONS AND COMMITTEE.
I SAID DOORSTEP IT'S GREAT THAT
WE KNOW WHAT TO DO AND IT'S
GREAT THAT WE KNOW HOW TO DO IT
WELL BUT WE HAVE TO DOCUMENT WE
HAVE TO SHOW IT. THAT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THE AUDITOR
POINTED OUT IS THERE WAS
LACKING DOCUMENTATION. AND SO
YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS SAY LOOK LET'S BE
CONSISTENT AND EXECUTE. AN
OBJECTIVE AND LEVEL AND FAIR
WAY. NOW THE OTHER PART OF THE
QUESTION I THINK CONCERNS.
FOLKS WHO WORK AT THE LOTTERY I
MADE IT A PRIORITY. THAT WE
TAKE CARE OF OUR PEOPLE. THIS
IS BEEN A SPECIAL CHALLENGE.OF
THE LAST NINETY DAYS. WELL
WE'VE HAD CO IN NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND ALSO THESE RECENT-
ISSUES WITH CIVIL UNREST. IN
FACT I'D QUESTION. EMAIL TO THE
ENTIRE STAFF JUST YESTERDAY. BY
AN OFFICE TACK. IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA LAST YEAR WARRANTY
SAYING ANYTHING ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON. AND I WROTE BACK
COPPING ALL AND I SAID LOOK.
I'M ON A LOT OF OTHER THINGS I
SAID WE HAVE TO. PRIORITIZE THE
SAFETY OF OUR ORANGE IS JOB
ONE. AND THEN WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON OUR MISSION. WHICH IS TO
MAXIMIZE FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS.
NOW AS WE PROGRESS THROUGH THIS
WE GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE A SAFE. AND HEALTHY
WORKPLACE THAT WE TREAT EACH
OTHER WITH PROFESSIONALISM AND
RESPECT. AND OTHERS DIVERSITY
AND INCLUSION. THIS SHOULD NOT
HAPPEN ENOUGH IN RECENT YEARS.
I THINK THERE IS SO MUCH OF A
FOCUS ON DRIVING SALES FOR THE
SAKE OF SALES BUT NOT ENOUGH
AFTER WAS MADE TOWARDS. MAKING
SURE THAT MANAGEMENT WAS BEING
DONE TO SERVICE THE NEEDS OF
THE MPLOYEES AND MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY FELT LIKE THEY WERE
DOING THE BEST THEY COULD.
TREAT EACH OTHER WITH FAIRNESS
AND RESPECT. THAT'S WHY WE'RE
WE'VE ALREADY ONCE JUST LAST
MONTH AN EMPLOYEE ENGAGEMENT
SURVEY. OR SENDING OUT
ANONYMOUS SURVEY TO ALL OVER A
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN EMPLOYEES
ASKING THEM TO BE FRANK ABOUT
WHAT WORKS WHAT COULD B DONE
BETTER. WE WANT TO USE THAT AS
FOUNDATION FOR A MISSION VISION
VALUES PROJECT WE'RE GOING TO
IDENTIFY YOU CAN CLARIFY THE
SHARED VALUES THAT BEST SERVE
OUR MISSION. I'VE SEEN AS
SOMEWHAT OF A LAUREL
ORGANIZATIONS I WORK AND HE WAS
MISSING AT THE LOTTERY SO
THAT'S WHY WE'RE DOING HERE THE
TRYING TO SHIFT THE- CULTURE TO
BE A BETTER ONE. GREAT I THANK
YOU FOR ANSWERING MY QUESTIONS.
AND AGAIN CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR APPOINTMENT. THANK THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN- I
APPRECIATE ALL THE QUESTIONS-
AND COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
BECAUSE- CERTAINLY. MINIMUM
PROTEST- SENATOR MINING I'M SO
SORRY. I JUST ASSUME YOUR
ORDERS TO IT IS WITH ME IT IN
NO I WILL CONCLUDE WITH ME AND
REDO THE RESPECTFUL THING AND
LET MY COLLEAGUE GO FIRST
SENATOR MINING THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING ME ACCOUNTABLE TO MY
OWN MY CONSISTENT PROCESS THANK
YOU. MADAM PRO TEM IN MR
JOHNSON- I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE TIME WE HAD TOGETHER-
EARLIER. THIS WEEK- LAST WEEK
WHENEVER WE SPOKE AND YOU
ANSWERED MANY MY QUESTIONS THEN
I DO THINK IT WOULD BE HELPFUL
FOR MY COLLEAGUES IN THE PUBLIC
TO HEAR- WHAT YOU ARE DOING- TO
PROTECT EMPLOYEES DURING COVERT
NINETEEN I ASKED THE SAME
QUESTION OF MISTER GORDON- BUT
WOULD APPRECIATE. YOUR COMMENTS
BOTH ON THE PROTOCOLS YOU'VE
PUT IN PLACE AND SPECIFICALLY-
THE NUMBER OF REPORTED CASES
AMONG EMPLOYEES AND WHERE THOSE
HAVE OCCURRED AND WHAT STEPS
YOU'RE TAKING TO PROTECT CO
WORKERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR THE QUESTION YOU
KNOW THIS IS ONE OF THE AREAS
WHERE IT BECAME REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE MANAGEMENT
FORMS WE'VE BEEN PUTTING IN
PLACE TO BEAR FRUIT BECAUSE WE
HAD TO OPEN UP LINES OF
COMMUNICATION. AND ENCOURAGE
TEAMWORK AND WHEN THIS ISSUE
CAME UPON US THAT BECAME
CRITICAL BROUGHT TOGETHER
EXECUTIVE TEAM AT ALL HOURS OF
THE DAY AND NIGHT AND ON
WEEKENDS TO TRY TO.
TROUBLESHOOT PROBLEMS ALL. ONE
OF THE FIRST THINGS WE DID AT
THE END OF FEBRUARY AS WE MADE
SURE THAT. AND SANITIZER CLOSE
DISINFECTING WIPES. PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT WAS MADE
AVAILABLE FOR ALL OF OUR
FACILITIES THAT WERE NON
HEADQUARTERS. AS WE MOVED IN
MARCH WE MAKE SURE THAT
CUSTODIAL STAFF AT OUR WATER
RELOCATIONS WE'RE CONDUCTING
MORE FREQUENT CLEANINGS OF
COMMON AREAS. AND HIGH TOUCH
SERVICES SUCH AS DOOR HANDLES
ELEVATOR BUTTONS CONTINUING ON
MARCH IS WHEN THINGS REALLY
START TO COME TO A HEAD. AND
THAT'S WHEN WE DEPLOYED OUR
EMERGENCY TELEWORK PROGRAM. WE
THOUGHT THIS MIGHT BE SOMETHING
THAT WE- DO AND SO BEFORE WE
EVEN RECEIVED DIRECTION FROM
STATE LEADERSHIP WE DECIDED.
LET'S FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE FOR THE LOTTERY. AND
WE STARTED IMPROVING AND
WALKING UP OUR- ELECTRONIC
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT FOLKS
AT HOME. AND I'M HAPPY TO SAY
THAT- OUR- FOLKS WERE WORKING-
INTEL WORKING CAPACITY RANGE
FROM 75% 290% OF OUR EMPLOYEES
DEPENDING ON THE DATE. AND THE
NEEDS. AND OUR INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SERVICES DIVISION
HAS BEEN INSTRUMENTAL MAKING
THAT SUCCESSFUL. IN ADDITION WE
ALSO STARTED WORK SCHEDULES TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE HAD
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND WE PUT IN
PLACE AS DRAWN UP BY OUR HUMAN
RESOURCE DEPARTMENT SPECIFIC
SOCIAL THIS THE SAME PROTOCOLS
USING THE PP STAYING APART- AND
OTHER THINGS THAT WILL HELP
PEOPLE STAY SAFE. HEARING ON IN
MARCH AMONG THE THINGS WE DID
WAS WE CLOSED OUR NINE DISTRICT
OFFICES PUBLIC. WE ALSO CLOSER
HEADQUARTERS BUILDING YOU'RE IN
SACRAMENTO. WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT- WE COULD DO WHAT WE
COULD TO LIMIT THE SPREAD AND
THAT BECAME VERY IMPORTANT FOR
US. WE'VE ADVISE FOLKS THROUGH
MULTIPLE CHANNELS THAT HAVE
LOTTERY PRIZES THAT THEY WANT
TO REGAIN THE CAN STILL DO THAT.
ONE OF THE KEY THINGS THAT OUR
TEAM MEMBERS DO IS THEY
ACTUALLY. VISIT RETAILERS TO
CHECK ON THEIR NEEDS AND MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE FULLY STOCKED
OUR PRODUCTS. AND WE'VE HAD TO
PUT IN CONTROLS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT'S DONE REMOTELY.
USUALLY BY TELEPHONE. SO THAT
WE CAN WIN AGAIN LIMIT
CONTACTED NGUYEN SPREAD. IN
ADDITION. SENSITIVE TO- THE
ANXIETY AND THE PUBLIC. AMONG
THE THINGS THAT WE DID WAS WE
PAUSE OUR PROMOTIONAL
ADVERTISING DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
WANT PEOPLE GOING TO THE STORE
JUST. BUY LOTTERY TICKETS- YOU
KNOW FOLKS GONNA WANT TO BUY IF
THEY WANT TO BUY BUT WE DIDN'T
WANT TO. DO THE TYPICAL
ADVERTISING THAT WE NORMALLY DO
BECAUSE YOU WANTED TO KEEP
THIS- UP DOWN PLATE. IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST. ARE WE ALSO
SLOW THE ROLL OUT WITH SOME OF
OUR GAMES INCLUDING- BEGIN THAT
SPRING. PRACTICE WE'RE HOPING
TO ONCE THAT LATER WHEN TIMES
ARE MORE PROGRAM. THANK YOU THE
OTHER PART OF MY QUESTION IS
HOW MANY. CASES HAVE BEEN
REPORTED AMONG EMPLOYEES AND
ONE OF THE PROTOCOLS. WHEN AN
EMPLOYEE TEST POSITIVE. WERE
SYMPTOMATIC. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION TODAY WE HAVE ONE SELF
REPORTED CASE OF AN EMPLOYEE
THAT IS STILL SUFFERING
SOMETIMES- DURING THE ENTIRE
PANDEMIC WE HAD A TOTAL TO SELF
REPORTED CASES- BUT RIGHT NOW
THERE'S JUST ONE THAT IS IN
KEEPING. ARE STILL DEALING WITH
THE OCTOBER NINETEEN BUYERS ARE
PROTOCOLS AND WE FIND OUT THAT-
THIS IS HAPPENED IS WE FIRST
DIRECT THOSE IMMEDIATE
FACILITIES BE DEEP CLEAN AND WE
NOTIFY THE OTHER PERSONNEL IN
THE AREA WE MAY HAVE BEEN IN
CONTACT WITH ABSOLUTE. THANK
YOU MY FINAL QUESTION. HOW DO
YOU RECONCILE OR QUARTER THE-
PROGRAMS OF THE LOTTERY. YOUR
MISSION IS TO MAXIMIZE SALES
BUT WE KNOW THERE ARE SOME
PROBLEM GAMBLERS- PEOPLE WHO
ARE SUSCEPTIBLE TO. THE DISEASE
OF GAMBLING. AND YOU HAVE
INTERMEDIARIES MARKETING THE
TICKETS AT RETAIL CENTERS- WHAT
DOES THE LOTTERY DUE TO. ON THE
ONE HAND MAXIMIZE SALES BUT ON
THE OTHER HAND TO PROTECT THOSE
FOR WHOM. THIS IS NOT AN
ENJOYABLE. PAST TIME BUT A
PREOCCUPATION IN A IN A DISEASE.
WELL WE MARKET THE LOTTERY AS
ENTERTAINMENT BUT IT IS
GAMBLING AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'VE DONE FOR MANY MANY
YEARS IS SUPPORT PROBLEM
GAMBLING PROGRAMS IN CAMPAIGNS
INCLUDING FOR EXAMPLE THE ONE
IN HUNDRED GAMBLER HOTLINE- WE
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT FOLKS WHO HAVE A PROBLEM
GET HELP. AND WE MAKE THAT VERY
CLEAR IN OUR ADVERTISING IN OUR
PROGRAMS AND THE PROGRAMS THAT
WE SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER
JOHNSON APPRECIATE YOUR-
LEADERSHIP IN IN GAME
CONGRATULATE YOU ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT THANK YOU MADAM PRO
TEM. THANK YOU SIR. SENATOR
MINING THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WAS ABOUT TO SAY I THINK AND
THEN YOU ADDED EVEN MORE
QUESTIONS OF IMPORTANCE
PARTICULARLY AROUND THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF EMPLOYEES AND I
KNOW AND PASSED OFF. A
CONFIRMATION IS THE ISSUE OF-
GAMBLING AND THAT BALANCE OF WE
WANT TO RAISE MORE MONEY FOR
EDUCATION BUT YOU KNOW HOW TO
YEAH HOW DO YOU BALANCE THAT I-
I PROBABLY HAVE A COUPLE
COMMENTS BUT THEIR COMMENTS AND
I WILL SAVE THEM- FOR AFTER WE
HEAR FROM OUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE FIRST. TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND DIRE
BEFORE I CHECK AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE LET ME GO
AHEAD AND REMIND WITNESSES
WISHING TO PROVIDE COMMENT VIA
PHONE THAT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AGAIN. IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE CODE.
IS. EIGHT FIVE SEVEN NINE SEVEN
FIVE ZERO. AND THAT IS ON THE
SCREEN SO. PEOPLE CAN T. UP AND
GET READY. OF FOR YOUR MOMENT
TO TESTIFY. IF YOU'RE CALLING
IN. SO HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE I WANT TO SEE IF WE
HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT.
OF OUR DIRECTOR- HERE NAIL-
COME FORWARD. I SEE NO ONE AT
THIS MOMENT SO- BELIEVE
PROBABLY THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE BUT LET'S GET A LOOK
AT ROOM ONE TWELVE. MAKE SURE
NO ONE STEPS FORWARD. OKAY WE
WILL ALL RIGHT NOW DIRECT OUR-
WITNESSES WHO WERE WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE. OUR FOR DIRECTOR
JOHNSON IN SUPPORT MISTER
MODERATOR I KNOW YOU'RE STILL
WITH US IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
APPOINTMENT WE WILL BEGIN. THE
GERMAN ON THE PHONE LINES IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT YOUR
TONE INDICATING PLACING QUEUE
YOU'LL BE ANNOUNCED BY THE
NUMBER THAT THE OPERATOR
PROVIDE TO. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND AT THE
MOMENT IT LOOKS LIKE WE DO HAVE
FIVE IN THE QUEUE. AND WE WILL
BE STARTING- WITH NUMBER TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF HIS
SCOTT WHAT YOUR BEHALF OF THE
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PATRIOTS COUNCIL IN THE WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL
WORKERS. I'VE KNOWN DIRECTOR
JOHNSON FOR MORE THAN TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AND I THINK WHAT
DISTINGUISHES HIS CAREER IS ONE
OF A CONSENSUS BUILDING IN
COLLABORATION BECAUSE WHEN.
WHEN HE WAS A EXECUTIVE WITHIN
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT. HE REACHED
OUT AND WORK WITH MY LABOR
CLIENTS COLLABORATIVELY AND WE
ALWAYS HAD A FANTASTIC
RELATIONSHIP AND I THINK THAT
SPEAKS VOLUMES FOR AND WE WOULD
URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT YEAR THE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JIM LIGHTS OF
CALIFORNIA STRATEGIES I'D LIKE
TO OFFER ONE LITTLE PIECE OF
MISTER JOHNSON'S HISTORY IN A
DIFFERENT TIME AT THE END OF
THE NINETEEN NINETY FIVE SPLIT
HOUSE NEAR IN THE ASSEMBLY WHEN
THE CHAIRMANSHIPS WERE SPLIT
BETWEEN THE TWO PARTIES. WHEN
THE REPUBLICANS CAPTURED
MAJORITY AT THE END OF THAT
YEAR AND THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS WORKING FOR
DEMOCRATIC CHAIRS INCLUDING ME
WERE TRANSITIONED OUT OF THOSE
POSITIONS ALPHA WAS THE ONLY
MOVIE CONSULTANT IN THE ENTIRE
HOUSE WORKING FOR A DEMOCRATIC
CHAIR. THAT WAS RETAINED BY THE
NEW INCOMING CHAIRMAN I THINK
THAT THERE'S QUITE A BIT ABOUT
WHO HE IS AND HOW HE HAS
CONDUCTED HIMSELF- THE POLICY
PROFESSIONAL OVER THE YEARS ON.
THE OPTICAL THE COURT HIS
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS EDWIN
LOMBARD I'M THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA BUT CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. OF KNOWN AL WITH
JOHNSON FOR ALL MORE THAN
FIFTEEN YEARS AND VARIOUS
CAPACITIES THROUGHOUT THE- HIS
PROFESSIONAL LIFE. HE IS TRULY
A MAN OF INTEGRITY AND HE'S
VERY STRATEGIC AND SYSTEMATIC
ABOUT THE WAY YOU GO ABOUT
DOING THINGS AND WE AT THE
CALIFORNIA BLACK CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE HIGHLY RECOMMEND HIM
FOR THE POSITION OF DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LAW. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY NEXT WITNESS. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO NUMBER TEN THE GUY
THAT. THE AFTERNOON YOU ARE
MADAM SPEAKER WILD MAN PRO TEM-
MY NAME IS SIMEON DAN. AND I AM
REPRESENTING THE- PORCHES
SCHOOL OF EDUCATION I HI
ACHIEVING CHARTER SCHOOL WITH
WILL ROUTE THEY TO CALIFORNIA-
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT AND I
DON'T MISTER ALBERT JOHN REPORT
NEARLY TWENTY FIVE YEARS WELL
AND- HE DID HAVE A HIGH LEVEL
OF EXPERIENCE BY I REALLY THINK
I'M TO THE POINT MAN. REALLY
AND HE IS THE ONE REALLY AND
HE'S REALLY GOOD STEWARDS OF.
THE STATE'S MONEY. AS TO THE
NEAREST. EXPLORE PUBLIC. ALL
WORK WITH HIM ON PEAK YOUR ON
ON PICTURES CALL IN EDUCATION
CALL AND ON JUST ONE I X. AS
FOR CAR THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO NUMBER TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM PRO TEM AND MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE-
CLAIMS ENTRY ENTRY I AM
TESTIFYING ON MY BEHALF I DON'T
KNOW QUITE ON THIS ISSUE- BUT I
JUST ADMIRED OF KNOWN- MISTER
JOHNSON FOR SO MANY YEARS. OF
OUR DAYS IN THE ASSEMBLY A
LITTLE BOX CHIEF CONSULTANT FOR
A ONE TIME I THINK. ON THE
CHIEF IT'S ONLY ONE NIGHT AFTER
AN AMERICAN STAFF- WE PROBABLY
HAVE A QUORUM ON THE CALL NOW-
BUT BEYOND THAT- MISTER
JOHNSON'S INTEGRITY IS
PROFESSIONALISM- WORKING IN
STATE GOVERNMENT AND THEN ALSO
A WORKING FOR MAJOR CARAMEL
INTEREST IN OTHER. CITIES HAS
ALWAYS BEEN. TRYING TO. PER DAY
ALL MAKE THE RIGHT. AND KIND OF.
ADDRESS ISSUES FROM ACROSS PER.
LITTLE FROM A POLICY DRIVEN
APPROACH I THINK HE HAS OF THE
SKILLS ON THE JOB. AND HE'S THE
RIGHT CHANGE AGENT- FOR THIS
DEPARTMENT AND- ON A PERSONAL
LEVEL I SUPPORT HIS APPOINTMENT
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER MODERATOR ARE THERE
OTHER CALLERS WAITING IN THE
QUEUE TO TESTIFY. NO ONE CAN IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL BE BACK
WITH YOU IN A FEW MOMENTS. LET
ME I'D NOW TURN TO- MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE APPOINTMENT.
WE WILL AGAIN START IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE IF THERE
IS A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD.
OKAY SEEING NONE I WILL MAKE
THE ASSUMPTION BUT WE WILL
CHECK THE SCREEN IS THERE
ANYONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WAITING. TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE MISTER MODERATOR WE
ARE BACK WITH YOU. TO HAVE YOU
SEE IF THERE ARE PEOPLE ON VIA
TELECONFERENCE WHO ARE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. AND
THOSE RUN THE PHONE LINES IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NOBODY IN THE QUEUE. OKAY
MISTER MODERATOR LET'S GIVE IT
ONE MORE MINUTE JUST TO MAKE
SURE WE GET EVERYONE WHO WANTS
TO TESTIFY. ABSOLUTELY AND ONCE
AGAIN- PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVEN'T DONE ANYTHING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR HELP
AND ASSISTANCE TODAY MISTER
MODERATOR. I WILL- BRING IT
BACK I HAVING HEARD FROM
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND NO ONE
IN OPPOSITION- NOTING THAT WE
DID GET THREE- EMAILS ARE FOR
THE RECORD. LET ME ASK IF ANY
OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OF THE CONFIRMATION
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH HOT LET
ME JUST QUICKLY ADD. YOU KNOW I
WANT TO THANK YOU DIRECTOR JOHN
SAID I- I HAPPEN TO NOTICES WE
WERE LISTENING TO. I DIRECTOR
GORDON TALK ABOUT CULTURE
CHANGE- I NOTICED YOU ON THE
SCREEN YOUR HEAD SHAKING UP AND
DOWN- CLEARLY AT YOU KNOW I
THINK- THAT YOU. CAME INTO A
SITUATION WHEN APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR UNDERSTANDING- THE
ROLE THAT YOU HAD TO PLAY WITH
AN ORGANIZATION. THAT WAS
CALLED INTO QUESTION FOR SOME
ACTIVITY WITHIN AUDIT WHICH BY
THE WAY. I ALSO AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE SENATOR ROTH ROTH.
THE STRICT PROPORTIONALITY-
ISSUES THAT WE TRIED TO
UNDERSTAND WHEN SOME OF THIS
CAME OUT THERE WERE QUESTIONS
ABOUT. WAS MONEY- TO SCHOOLS OR
NOT- AT THAT TIME I RECALL ON
UNDERSTANDING BETWEEN THE
AUDITOR AND OUR STATE
CONTROLLER. THAT THERE MIGHT BE
SOME TECHNICAL THINGS THAT
NEEDED TO BE CLARIFIED- IN
LEGISLATION OR- ARE THROUGH OUR
OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO HELP MAKE
THIS EASIER. I WANT TO COMMEND
YOU FOR STEPPING UP TO THE
CHALLENGE AND I CERTAINLY HOPE
THAT AS IT RELATES TO CULTURE
CHANGE AND- AND THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO- WITH STAFF
TO BE BOTH SUPPORTIVE OF THEM
BUT ALSO HOLDING PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE. ARE WE WANT YOU TO
BE SUCCESSFUL I APPRECIATE YOUR
ANSWERING HARD QUESTIONS TODAY-
VERY MUCH. AND I WISH YOU ALL
THE SUCCESS- IN THE WORLD- AS
YOU AS YOU DO CONTINUE TO
UNDERTAKE THIS I CAN GET MY
COLLEAGUES. FURTHER THOUGHTFUL
QUESTIONS OF MADAM SECRETARY I
WILL ASK YOU TO CALL THE ROLL.
THREE YEAR. I CALLED HER ON.
MONNING I RUNNING A HIGH ROTH
HI I WILK. WILL NOT VOTING
ATKINS HI ATKINS I. THREE ZERO
THREE TO ZERO THE CONFIRMATION
IS CONFIRMED- OR THE%
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRM THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH US
TODAY. CONGRATULATIONS THANK
YOU FOR. OKAY TO MY COLLEAGUES
I THINK WE HAVE NO FURTHER
BUSINESS TODAY SO I WILL
ADJOURN THE MEETING AND THANK
YOU MADAM SECRETARY.